[APPLAUSE]
>> Announcer: PLEASE
WELCOME THE CEO OF GOOGLE,
SUNDAR PICHAI!
[APPLAUSE]
>> WELCOME TO NEXT.
THANK YOU ALL SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US.
I THINK WE ARE
BEING JOINED BY MANY,
MANY PEOPLE ON THE
LIVESTREAM AS WELL
SO THANKS TO ALL OF
THEM FOR JOINING AS WELL.
IT'S BEEN A
REALLY EXCITING FEW
MONTHS FOR GOOGLE CLOUD.
IN MARCH, ONE
OF OUR CLOUD DEVELOPER
ADVOCATES, EMMA HARUKA IWAO,
BROKE THE GUINESS
WORLD RECORD FOR CALCULATING 31.4
TRILLION DIGITS OF PI.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
THAT WAS MY
REACTION AS WELL WHEN
I FIRST HEARD IT.
SHE DID IT BY RUNNING GOOGLE
COMPUTE ENGINE CONTINUOUSLY
TO READ 10 TERABYTES OF DATA.
IT REALLY SHOWS THE RELIABILITY
OF THE PRODUCT. I HOPE TO READ
u c  THE WHOLE NUMBER OUT HERE,
BUT I DON'T
THINK I HAVE ENOUGH
TIME FOR IT.FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO FOLLOW
COLLEGE BASKETBALL, LAST NIGHT
WAS QUITE A GAME.
GOOGLE CLOUD
HAS A GREAT
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE NCAA,
AND THIS
YEAR, WE INVITED
SOME COLLEGE STUDENT DEVELOPERS
TO JOIN IN
THE FUN. THEY HELPED
US MAKE SOME PREDICTIONS
USING
80 YEARS WORTH
OF BASKETBALL DATA,
AND SOME
OF THE DEVELOPERS ARE
HERE WITH US TODAY,
OUR FUTURE CIOs
AND CEOs. LET'S GIVE THEM A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE.
[APPLAUSE]
THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE. YOU'VE HELPED
US TAKE OFFICE PRACTICE
TO AN
ENTIRELY NEW LEVEL AT
GOOGLE. AND TRUST ME,
YOU DON'T WANT
TO BE IN A
POOL WITH THOMAS KURIAN.
AT GOOGLE, NOTHING
EXCITES US MORE
THAN SOLVING A PROBLEM,
EXCEPT MAYBE
SOLVING A PROBLEM AT
SCALE. WE'VE ALWAYS HAD
THE AMBITION
TO USE TECHNOLOGY TO
IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
AS MANY PEOPLE
AS POSSIBLE. AND ENTERPRISE
GIVES US AN OPPORTUNITY
TO APPROACH THIS
IN A PROFOUND WAY
BY DIRECTLY WORKING TOGETHER
WITH COMPANIES,
BUSINESSES, AND INSTITUTIONS
THAT POWER OUR
GLOBAL ECONOMY
AND DRIVE IMPORTANT
CHANGES IN OUR SOCIETY.
CLOUD IS
ONE OF THE LARGEST
AREAS OF INVESTMENT FOR
GOOGLE AS A COMPANY,
SO WE ARE TRULY ON
THIS JOURNEY WITH YOU TOGETHER.
AND WE ARE IN
IT FOR THE VERY LONG TERM.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
ARE A GREAT TECHNOLOGY
PARTNER TO ALL OF YOU.I'D
LIKE TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT THREE
AREAS TODAY; GROWING
OUR WORLD CLASS
INFRASTRUCTURE,
BRINGING INNOVATIVE
TECHNOLOGIES TO EVERYONE,
AND BUILDING
OPEN ECOSYSTEMS TO
HELP YOUR BUSINESSES THRIVE.
FOR OVER
20 YEARS, WE'VE BEEN SCALING
OUR TECHNOLOGY INFRASTRUCTURE
TO MATCH
THE GROWTH OF
INFORMATION. WE CONTINUE
TO INVEST
IN THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT MADE GOOGLE SUCCESSFUL
AND THAT
NOW POWERS GOOGLE CLOUD.
OUR CUSTOM SERVER HARDWARE
AND DATA CENTERS
CAN BRING AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF COMPUTING POWER
TO PEOPLE ALL
OVER THE WORLD. WE ARE
IN OVER 200 COUNTRIES AND
TERRITORIES, CONNECTED
BY HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF MILES OF
FIBER OPTIC
CABLE.IN FACT, WE RECENTLY
LAID OUR OWN CABLE
UNDER THE PACIFIC,
AND NOW WE ARE DOING
THE SAME UNDER THE ATLANTIC.
WE HAVE 19 CLOUD REGIONS
AND 58 DATA CENTERS LIVE. AND
TODAY I'M EXCITED TO TELL YOU
THAT WE ARE BRINGING TWO NEW
LOCATIONS ONLINE, ONE IN SEOUL
AND ONE IN SALT LAKE CITY.
[APPLAUSE]
JUST TO GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF SCALE IN A
FUN WAY, SIX YEARS AGO,
OUR DATA
CENTER CAPITAL PLAN INCLUDED
ABOUT TWO EIFFEL TOWERS
WORTH OF STEEL. THIS
YEAR'S PLAN INCLUDES ENOUGH STEEL
TO BUILD 20 EIFFEL TOWERS. THAT'S
A WHOLE LOT OF STEEL.
THIS SHOWS THE SCALE
OF OUR INFRASTRUCTURE.
REGARDLESS OF THE BUSINESS
YOU'RE IN, WE WANT
TO HELP YOU USE
THE
MOST ADVANCED TECHNOLOGIES
TO DRIVE INNOVATION.
IT'S AN
INCREDIBLE TIME TO
BE DEVELOPING CLOUD TECHNOLOGY
AND USING IT
TO SOLVE PROBLEMS. WHETHER IT'S
USING AI TO HELP SHIPS
NAVIGATE
SAFELY, CONNECTING OFFLINE
AND ONLINE RETAIL
WITH
PERSONALIZED EXPERIENCES, OR
USING MACHINE LEARNING
TO HELP
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS DETECT
FRAUD, WE KNOW THESE
SOLUTIONS ARE ONLY
HELPFUL TO YOUR BUSINESS
IF THEY ARE FULLY
ACCESSIBLE AND EASY
TO USE. THAT'S WHY
WE ARE SCALING UP
OUR TEAMS SO
WE CAN SPEND MORE
TIME WITH YOU, UNDERSTANDING
YOUR MOST
IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITIES. AND
IT'S BEEN EXCITING
TO SEE
THE MOMENTUM WE ARE
BUILDING TODAY TOGETHER.
IN FACT, TODAY, GOOGLE
CLOUD IS WORKING WITH MOST
OF THE TOP 10 COMPANIES
ACROSS
MEDIA AND
ENTERTAINMENT AND RETAIL.
AND HALF
OF THE TOP
TEN FINANCIAL SERVICES FIRMS.
AS WELL AS MANY OTHER SECTORS
AND INDUSTRIES.
WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR OUR PARTNERS
WHO ARE HELPING US EXTEND
OUR REACH AND MAKE
OUR CUSTOMERS SUCCESSFUL.
THOMAS IS GOING TO BE
SHARING A NUMBER OF NEW AND
IMPORTANT CUSTOMER AND PARTNER
ANNOUNCEMENTS
OVER THE
COMING DAYS.
GOOGLE ALSO HAS A
20 YEAR HISTORY OF
BUILDING TRULY OPEN ECOSYSTEMS
FOR EVERYONE. AND
WE WANT TO DO THE
SAME FOR ENTERPRISE COMPUTING.
TODAY, MOST
OF THE WORLD'S ENTERPRISE
COMPUTING STILL HAPPENS
ON PREMISE. IT
HASN'T MOVED TO THE
CLOUD YET BECAUSE THE
PATH FORWARD IS
COMPLEX AND DAUNTING AND
FULL OF DIFFICULT DECISIONS.
HOW DO YOU MODERNIZE
IN PLACE WITHOUT HAVING TO
JUMP COMPLETELY TO THE CLOUD?
HOW DO YOU BRIDGE
INCOMPARABLE ARCHITECTURES
WHILE YOU TRANSITION?
AND HOW
DO YOU MAINTAIN FLEXIBILITY
AND AVOID LOCK IN?
WE HAVE FACED SIMILAR
CHALLENGES AS A COMPANY
IN OUR OWN BUSINESS.
THE MASSIVE
RESOURCE REQUIREMENTS OF
OUR OWN CLOUD SERVICES,
BE IT SEARCH,
MAPS AND GMAIL, DEMANDED
EVERY OUNCE OF COMPUTING POWER
FROM OUR SERVERS.
BUT WE NEEDED TO MAINTAIN
FLEXIBILITY TO ADAPT TO SHIFTING
USER DEMANDS AND
WE REALLY WANTED TO BE
EASY TO SHIP BETWEEN JOBS.
THIS LED
TO OUR EARLY
EXPERIMENTATION WITH CONTAINERS,
AND WE
DEVELOPED OUR OWN INTERNAL
CLUSTER MANAGEMENT TOOL, BORG.
AND AS WE
DEVELOPED GOOGLE CLOUD,
WE WANTED EVERYONE
TO BE
ABLE TO USE BORG
FOR THEIR COMPUTING NEEDS.
AND THE
RESULT WAS OUR
OPEN SOURCE EFFORT KUBERNETES.
TODAY, IT
IS THE INDUSTRY
STANDARD FOR RUNNING
AND MANAGING
CONTAINERS. AND LAST
YEAR, WE ANNOUNCED THE
CLOUD SERVICES
PLATFORM TO ALLOW
YOU TO MANAGE KUBERNETES
BOTH ON PREM
AND ON GOOGLE CLOUD.
IT GAVE BUSINESSES A
SECURE MANAGED
SOLUTION AND IT
GAVE DEVELOPERS A COMMON
DEVELOPMENT PLATFORM.
IT WAS A HUGE
STEP FORWARD, BUT IT
STILL LEFT
ONE MAJOR CUSTOMER
PROBLEM UNSOLVED. IT DIDN'T
MAKE IT EASY
FOR YOU ALL TO SPAN
MULTIPLE CLOUD PROVIDERS.
SO, WE'VE BEEN HARD
AT WORK AND WE
HAVE SPENT THE LAST YEAR
DEVELOPING A
PRODUCT THAT GIVES YOU
THE FLEXIBILITY TO MAKE
THE BEST DECISIONS
FOR YOUR BUSINESS NOW
AND IN THE FUTURE.
WE THINK WE
HAVE THE ANSWER, AND
I'M PROUD TO INTRODUCE YOU
TO THAT PRODUCT
TODAY. WE CALL IT ANTHOS.
ANTHOS   [APPLAUSE]
ANTHOS IS BASED
ON KUBERNETES. IT
RUNS ON PREMISE,
BUT IT
ALSO SUPPORTS MULTI
AND HYBRID CLOUD ENVIRONMENTS
AND IS
FULLY MANAGED BY GOOGLE.
IT BRINGS TOGETHER THE
SIMPLICITY OF
OPEN SOURCE PLATFORMS,
OUR DEEP TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE, AND
THE FREEDOM TO
CHOOSE THE RIGHT CLOUD
PARTNER FOR YOUR
JOB. IT LETS YOU WRITE
ONCE AND RUN YOUR
JOBS ANYWHERE, IN OUR
CLOUD, IN YOUR DATA
CENTER, OR ON OTHER
CLOUD PROVIDERS. IT
GIVES YOU THE FLEXIBILITY
TO MOVE ON PREM APPS
TO THE CLOUD WHEN YOU'RE
READY, AND IT ALLOWS YOU TO KEEP
USING THE TECHNOLOGIES YOU ARE
ALREADY USING WHILE IMPROVING
SECURITY.WE HAVE BUILT
ANTHOS TO BE SIMPLE,
FLEXIBLE AND SECURE,
ALL THE THINGS YOU'D
WANT IN A GREAT
TECHNOLOGY PARTNER.
AND THANK YOU
FOR GIVING US THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO BE
THAT PARTNER.I'M GOING TO
TURN IT OVER TO
THOMAS KURIAN TO
GIVE YOU ALL THE
DETAILS. THOMAS HAS ONLY
BEEN LEADING
GOOGLE CLOUD FOR ABOUT
TEN WEEKS NOW, BUT
MANY OF YOU
PROBABLY KNOW HIM FROM
MORE THAN TWO DECADES
OF EXPERIENCE SERVING
ENTERPRISE CUSTOMERS. IN HIS
SHORT TIME AT GOOGLE,
HE'S ALREADY
MET WITH HUNDREDS
OF CUSTOMERS AND PARTNERS.
I THINK HIS
PERSONAL PRODUCTIVITY IS TESTING
THE LIMITS OF GSUITE AND CALENDAR.
HE'S A TREMENDOUS
LEADER WITH A POWERFUL
VISION, AND I'M INCREDIBLY
EXCITED TO HAVE
HIM LEADING GOOGLE CLOUD.
THOMAS, TAKE IT AWAY.
[APPLAUSE]
>>THOMAS KURIAN: THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, SUNDAR.
AND A WORD OF THANKS
TO DIANE GREEN
WHO SPENT SO MANY
YEARS HELPING BUILD GOOGLE CLOUD,
AND SHE
RETIRED EARLIER THIS YEAR,
AND I'M VERY GRATEFUL
FOR HER LEADERSHIP
OF GOOGLE CLOUD FOR
SO MANY YEARS.
[APPLAUSE]
NOW, WE AT GOOGLE
CLOUD HAVE A VERY
CLEAR VISION ON WHAT
WE WANT
TO OFFER CUSTOMERS IN
A NUMBER OF INDUSTRIES
WHO
ARE GOING
THROUGH DIGITAL TRANFORMATION.
WE WANT
TO GIVE THEM
GLOBAL SCALE, DISTRIBUTED,
SECURE
INFRASTRUCTURE, A
DIGITAL TRANSFORMATION PLATFORM
THAT HELPS
PEOPLE BUILD INNOVATIVE
DIGITAL TRANSFORMATION SOLUTIONS,
AND THEN
INDUSTRY SPECIFIC CAPABILITY
FOR DIGITAL TRANSFORMATION
IN A
NUMBER OF INDUSTRIES.THE
FIRST IMPORTANT ANNOUNCEMENT
WE ARE MAKING
HERE AT NEXT IS ANTHOS.
IT CAME FROM OUR LISTENING
TO CUSTOMERS
WHO WANTED THREE
IMPORTANT THINGS FROM
THEIR CLOUD PROVIDERS.
FIRST, THE ABILITY TO
HAVE A TECHNOLOGY STACK
THAT THEY
COULD RUN IN THEIR
DATA CENTER NEXT TO
ENTERPRISE WORK LOADS
THAT THEY COULDN'T YET
MOVE TO THE CLOUD.
HYBRID
CLOUD.SECOND, A
SINGLE PROGRAMMING MODEL
THAT GAVE
THEM THE CHOICE AND
FLEXIBILITY TO MOVE WORKLOADS
TO BOTH
GOOGLE CLOUD, AS WELL
AS OTHER CLOUD PROVIDERS
WITHOUT ANY
CHANGE.AND THIRD, A
PLATFORM THAT ALLOWS THEM
TO OPERATE
THIS INFRASTRUCTURE WITHOUT
COMPLEXITY AND TO
SECURE AND
MANAGE ACROSS MULTIPLE
CLOUDS IN A SINGLE,
CONSISTENT WAY.TO
SHOW YOU THESE
CAPABILITIES, AND TO TALK
TO YOU IN
MORE DETAIL, LET ME WELCOME
EYAL MENOR FROM OUR
ENGINEERING ORGANIZATION WHO'S
ONE OF THE
LEADERS IN OUR
PRODUCT
DEVELOPMENT FOR
ANTHOS. EYAL?
>> THANK
YOU, THOMAS. IN
BUILDING GOOGLE CLOUD,
WE HAVE HEARD
FROM MANY OF YOU ABOUT
THE CHALLENGES YOU FACE TODAY.
I'M LUCKY TO
GET TO MEET CIOs
OF LARGE COMPANIES OFTEN.
FOR INSTANCE,
A LARGE RETAIL ENTERPRISE
CIO RECENTLY TOLD ME,
I'D LIKE TO
BUILD ME A FUTURE SOLELY
BASED ON OPEN SOURCE TECHNOLOGIES
THAT CAN BE
CLOUD AGNOSTIC. THAT IS
THE ONLY WAY FOR ME
TO REDUCE RISK
AS WE INVEST MORE
AND MORE IN THE CLOUD.
I HEAR FROM SO
MANY OF YOU THAT
YOU NEED TO MOVE FASTER
TO STAY COMPETITIVE
AND GAIN AN EDGE.
TIME TO MARKET FOR PRODUCTS
AND SERVICES
HAS SHORTENED DRAMATICALLY
FROM YEARS TO DAYS.
YOU WANT INNOVATION
TO BE A STRATEGIC
ENABLER FOR YOUR BUSINESS.
THE CLOUD
PROMISES A PATH
FORWARD WITH NEW TECHNOLOGIES,
MANAGED SERVICES
AND AN ECOSYSTEM
TO HELP YOU SUCCEED.
HOWEVER, THE
REALITY IS THAT MANAGING
HYBRID OR MULTI CLOUD
COMPUTE CAN
BE INCREDIBLY CHALLENGING
AND COMPLEX. TODAY,
80 PERCENT OF
WORKLOADS ARE STILL NOT IN
THE CLOUD. THERE IS A
VERY REAL RISK
OF BEING LOCKED IN BY
INVESTING TOO MUCH IN A
SINGLE CLOUD.ANALYSTS
ESTIMATE THAT 88
PERCENT OF
COMPANIES ARE EXPECTED
TO ADOPT A
MULTI CLOUD STRATEGY.
EACH CLOUD
COMES WITH ITS
OWN PROPRIETARY INFRASTRUCTURE
AND PROPEIRETARY
APIs AND THAT CREATES
A STRAIN ON YOUR
PRECIOUS
TALENT AND ADDS
COST.USING MULTIPLE CLOUDS
WITHOUT A
STRATEGIC PLAN IS A
GUARANTEED WAY TO INCREASE
OPERATIONAL COST
AND FRAGMENT YOUR
DEVELOPERS AND OPERATORS,
AND ALL OF THAT
CAN JUST ADD RISK. AND
NONE OF US ARE DOING
THIS BECAUSE WE
WANT MORE RISK, THAT'S FOR
SURE.TO HELP YOU SUCCEED
IN THIS WORLD.
SORRY. LAST YEAR AT
NEXT, WE INTRODUCED GOOGLE CLOUD
SERVICES PLATFORM,
OUR HYBRID PRODUCT<
THAT SUNDAR MENTIONED.
OVER THE PAST
EIGHT MONTHS, WE HAVE
PARTNERED WITH SOME OF YOU
WHO WERE
EARLY ADOPTERS TO
SOLVE THESE CHALLENGES.
THANK YOU FOR
BEING A PART OF
THIS JOURNEY WITH US.
AND THANK YOU
FOR OUR TEAM FOR
ALL THE HARD WORK SINCE.
TODAY, WE ARE
EXCITED TO ANNOUNCE
THAT THIS PLATFORM, ANTHOS,
IS
NOW GENERALLY AVAILABLE
FOR EVERYONE.
[APPLAUSE]
THANK YOU. USING OUR
PLATFORM, YOU CAN BUILD
AND DEPLOY APPS RAPIDLY,
BOTH ON PREMISE
AND IN THE CLOUD
WITH SECURITY BUILT IN.
YOU CAN TRULY
BUILD IT ONCE AND RUN
ANYWHERE. AND THERE IS MORE.
TODAY, WE ARE
ALSO EXCITED TO ANNOUNCE
THAT WE ARE EMBARKING
ON A
MULTI CLOUD JOURNEY. ANTHOS
IS GOING MULTI CLOUD.
IF
YOU ARE USING
MULTIPLE COMPUTE ENVIRONMENTS,
ANTHOS IS THE
CHOICE FOR YOU. IT
LOWERS YOUR IT COST WITH
THE LATEST
MANAGED OPEN SOURCE
AND HAS SECURITY
LAYERS INTEGRATED
RIGHT OUT OF
THE BOX. WITH ANTHOS,
YOU CAN
MODERNIZE ON PREMISE RIGHT
NOW. YOU CAN ACTUALLY
INSTALL AND
START RUNNING IN
LESS THAN THREE HOURS.
IT PROVIDES
MONITORING, LOGGING, VISIBILITY
AND CI/CD TOOLING
SO YOU
CAN INCREASE YOUR
DEVELOPER AND OPERATOR VELOCITY
ON PREMISE
AND IN THE CLOUD
IN A CONSISTENT WAY.
THIS IS THE NEW
REALITY WE ARE BRINGING
TO YOU. YOU SHOULD
BE ABLE
TO DEPEND ON
INCREASING LEVELS OF AUTOMATION
AND FOCUS
ON WHAT'S HAPPENING
FURTHER UP THE STACK
AND TAKE
THE INFRASTRUCTURE ALMOST
FOR GRANTED. YOU SHOULD
BE ABLE TO
DEPLOY NEW AND EXISTING
APPS RUNNING ON PREMISE
AND IN
THE CLOUDS WITHOUT HAVING
TO INVEST IN CONSTANTLY
RE TRAINING
YOUR DEVELOPERS. YOU
CAN TRULY DOUBLE DOWN
ON DELIVERING BUSINESS
VALUE. NOT ONLY HAVE
WE BUILT THIS TECHNOLOGY
BUT WE
HAVE WORKED WITH
MULTIPLE KEY ECOSYSTEM PARTNERS
TO BRING
ANTHOS TO YOU. GOOGLE
CLOUD AND OUR PARTNERS
ARE WITH YOU
EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY, BRINGING TO YOU
A PLATFORM THAT YOU CAN USE
EVERYWHERE YOU NEED IT. THANK YOU.
AND BACK TO YOU, THOMAS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, EYAL. AS HE
MENTIONED, WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH A NUMBER
OF PARTNERS TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR CUSTOMERS
CAN INTER
OPERATE THESE PARTNER
SOLUTIONS WITH GOOGLE TECHNOLOGY.
IT'S MY GREAT
PLEASURE NOW TO WELCOME
TO GOOGLE CLOUD NEXT
ONE OF
OUR PARTNERS, DAVID
GECKLER, EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT OF CISCO
SYSTEMS. PLEASE GIVE HIM A
WARM WELCOME. DAVID.
>> HEY, THOMAS. HOW YOU DOING.
>>> WELCOME TO NEXT.
>> GREAT GROUP YOU GOT HERE.
>> YES.DAVID, CISCO HAS BUILT
AN INCREDIBLE NETWORKING
AND SECURITY FRANCHISE,
HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CUSTOMERS
AROUND THE WORLD.
GIVEN YOUR SCALE AND MARKET
SHARE, YOU HAVE THE ABILITY
TO ENGAGE WITH A MASSIVE GLOBAL
CUSTOMER BASE. WHAT
ARE YOU HEARING
FROM YOUR CUSTOMERS?
>> WELL, LOOK, I
THINK YOU GUYS ARE HITTING IT
EXACTLY RIGHT HERE TODAY. I
MEAN, THE WORLD HAS
LANDED ON HYBRID CLOUD.
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY
A HUGE AMOUNT OF
CLOUD ADOPTION
GOING ON. NOT SURPRISING, THE
CLOUD IS THE
SEMINAL TECHNOLOGY TREND OF
OUR AREA, BUT I
THINK THE WAY
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT IT
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS HAS
BEEN VERY APPLICATION CENTRIC,
WHICH MAKES A LOT
OF SENSE. HEY,
THE APPLICATION IS MOVING
TO THE CLOUD. BUT
WHEN YOU LOOK
AT IT FROM THE
CIO'S PERSPECTIVE IN THE
ENTERPRISE, IT'S
MORE OF AN EXPANSION
MOTION, WHICH IS HEY,
NOW MY
APPLICATION IS MOVING TO
THE CLOUD. I HAVE
APPLICATIONS STILL IN
MY DATA CENTER, AS
YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT HERE.
I MAY HAVE
APPLICATIONS ON THE EDGE
OF MY NETWORK, AND
NOW I HAVE
TO CONNECT ALL OF
MY USERS TO THESE APPLICATIONS.
AND WHAT
WE'RE FINDING IS THAT'S
CHANGING THE ENTIRE IT
TECHNOLOGY STACK
UNDERNEATH, AND THE
ENTERPRISE IS HAVING
TO THINK
ABOUT THEIR ENTIRE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND HOW DO I
ARCHITECT THAT
DIFFERENTLY FOR THE
REALITIES OF THE CLOUD.
THAT BRINGS A LOT
OF COMPLEXITY, AND I THINK
IT'S ON US AS THE
INDUSTRY TO
WORK TOGETHER TO TRY
AND PUSH BACK AGAINST
THAT COMPLEXITY
AND HELP THEM DRIVE
TO MORE SIMPLICITY.
>> SO
WE'VE BEEN WORKING
TOGETHER SINCE 2017.
WHAT'S YOUR VISION
FOR HOW WE'RE SIMPLIFYING
THINGS FOR CUSTOMERS?
>> LOOK, I MEAN,
I THINK THIS HAS
BEEN A GREAT COLLABORATION,
AND IT STARTED
THE RIGHT WAY. IT STARTED WITH
AN ENGINEERING LED COLLABORATION.
SO I REMEMBER
EERS AND I HAD
A CONVERSATION BACK IN 2017,
AND WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
WHOLE ADOPTION OF CLOUD,
AND I REMEMBER
EERS' STATEMENT, THE WORLD
NEEDS A LIGHTED PATH
TO THE
CLOUD, AND I THOUGHT
THAT WAS VERY INSIGHTFUL
BECAUSE THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WE WERE
SEEING IN OUR CUSTOMERS,
AND
WE HAVE HIGHLY
COMPLEMENTARY TECHNOLOGY BASES.
I MEAN, WHAT CISCO
IS ALL ABOUT, THE
FRANCHISE I RUN IS
CONNECTING USERS
TO APPLICATIONS AND
DOING THAT SECURELY,
AND, YOU KNOW,
ALL THE PIECES IN
BETWEEN DOING THAT, OBVIOUSLY
GOOGLE BRINGS
UNBELIEVABLE CLOUD
TECHNOLOGY AND
KUBERNETES TO THE
EQUATION, SO WE THOUGHT,
HEY, CAN WE PUT
OUR TECHNOLOGY
STACKS TOGETHER AND
DELIVER A VERY
DIFFERENTIATED SOLUTION TO
OUR CUSTOMERS IN THIS HYBRID AND
MULTI CLOUD WORLD.
>> WHAT
MAKES OUR
PARTNERSHI UNIQUE?
>> LOOK, I THINK
IT'S UNIQUE FOR A COUPLE
OF REASONS. FIRST OF ALL,
I THINK WE
START WITH THE PREMISE OF
HYBRID AND MULTI CLOUD, RIGHT?
IT'S NOT
ABOUT THE CLOUD
WORKING BACKWARDS; IT'S ABOUT
THE REALITIES
OF THE ENVIRONMENT THAT
ALL OF OUR CUSTOMERS
LIVE IN TODAY,
AND THEN WE'RE GOING ABOUT
IT WITH  THE START
FROM THE CONCEPT,
A VERY OPEN, AND
OBVIOUSLY GOOGLE BRINGS THAT,
CISCO BRINGS THAT.
THE IDEA WE NEED
TO BUILD OPEN ECOSYSTEMS
THE PEOPLE AROUND
US CAN EMBRACE AND
EXTEND. IT'S NOT ALL
ABOUT JUST
OUR TWO TECHNOLOGIES. I
THINK THOSE ARE IMPORTANT
TECHNOLOGIES, BUT
WE'RE BRINGING TOGETHER
A TECHNOLOGY BASE
THAT'S OPEN
AND EXTENSIBLE AND OUR
CUSTOMERS CAN TAKE THAT
AND DRIVE IT
AND HELP PUSH BACK
ON SOME OF THIS COMPLEXITY
THAT'S COMING INTO
THEIR NETWORK WITH THE
ADOPTION OF CLOUD.
>> THANK YOU
SO MUCH, DAVID, FOR
YOUR PARTNERSHIP AND FOR
YOUR TEAM'S WORK WITH US.
>> ALL RIGHT.
CONGRATULATIONS WHAT YOU'RE
DOING HERE TODAY.
IT'S IMPACTING THE WHOLE INDUSTRY.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> ALL RIGHT. TAKE CARE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> SO
WE WANTED TO SHOW
YOU NOW ANTHOS LIVE.
WE WANT TO
SHOW YOU HOW EASY IT
IS TO BUILD A WORKLOAD,
RUN IT IN
YOUR DATA CENTER, MOVE
IT TO MULTIPLE CLOUDS
WITHOUT A
SINGLE LINE OF CODE
NEEDING TO BE CHANGED.
LET ME
WELCOME JENNIFER LIN
FROM OUR PRODUCT ORGANIZATION
TO SHOW YOU ANTHOS. JENNIFER.
[APPLAUSE]
>> AS A
PLATFORM ADMINISTRATOR, YOU
HAVE A DIFFICULT JOB.
YOU HAVE
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
KEEPING YOUR COMPANY
AHEAD OF
THE COMPETITION. THIS
MEANS ENABLING YOUR DEVELOPERS
AND
HELPING THEM DEPLOY
NEW APPLICATIONS AND
FEATURES FAST
WHILE KEEPING YOUR
BUSINESS STABLE AND SECURE.
YOU'RE
WORKING WITH EXISTING
AND NEW APPLICATIONS,
SOME ON VIRTUAL MACHINES,
AND INCREASINGLY
OTHERS IN CONTAINERS.
TODAY WE'RE EAGER TO
SHOW YOU MORE OF
ANTHOS, WHAT WE BELIEVE
IS GOING TO BE
THE CLOUD PLATFORM OF CHOICE
FOR MANY YEARS TO COME,
THE PLATFORM THAT
GIVES YOU THE FREEDOM
TO DO WHAT YOU WANT,
HOW YOU WANT,
AND WHERE YOU WANT. AND
WE'RE HERE TO HELP YOU.
ONE THING THAT'S
TOP OF MIND
FOR EVERYONE IS MIGRATION
AND MODERNIZATION.
IT'S BEEN REALLY
EXCITING TO WORK WITH
OUR CUSTOMERS
ON CRAFTING A JOURNEY
THAT'S RIGHT FOR THEM,
AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE AS MANY OPTIONS
AS POSSIBLE.
SO HOW CAN ANTHOS
HELP? TODAY WE'RE REALLY
PROUD TO
ANNOUNCE AN UPCOMING
NEW DATA, ANTHOS MIGRATE.
ANTHOS MIGRATE
LETS YOU MODERNIZE
YOUR WORKLOADS DIRECTLY
INTO
CONTAINERS AND KUBERNETES,
WHICH MEANS BENEFITS
LIKE
MODERN CONTROLS, LOWER
COSTS, MORE AUTOMATION
AND PORTABILITY
ACROSS CLOUDS. AS IF
THAT WASN'T GOOD ENOUGH,
ANTHOS MIGRATE
WILL DO THIS
VM TO CONTAINER CONVERSION
AUTOMATICALLY
WITHOUT REQUIRING
VM MODIFICATIONS
OR APP
RE WRITES BEFOREHAND. THAT'S
A BIG, BIG DEAL.
AT GOOGLE CLOUD,
WE ARE ALL ABOUT
SEEING IS BELIEVING.
SO HOW ABOUT A DEMO?
[APPLAUSE]
RIGHT NOW, YOU
CAN SEE A TYPICAL
DEPLOYMENT OF VMs RUNNING
ON ON PREM
VM WARE. THIS PARCITULAR
VM HERE IS RUNNING
OUR E COMMERCE
SITE THE ONLINE BOUTIQUE. IT'S
RUNNING ON A VM TODAY,
BUT THAT MEANS IT
HAS TO PATCH IT WHILE TRYING
TO AVOID DISRUPTION.
THEY'VE GOT TO
BUY MORE HARDWARE
TO SUPPORT BLACK FRIDAY
AND THEN HAVE
THAT HARDWARE SIT IDLE FOR
THE REST OF THE YEAR.
AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY, THEY'VE GOT
TO PAINSTAKINGLY PROTECT
THEIR CUSTOMER DATA.
THERE'S GOT TO BE
A BETTER WAY, RIGHT?
THIS SITE COULD
BENEFIT IN SO MANY
WAYS FROM RUNNING AS
A CONTAINER
INSTEAD. IT GETS
AWAY FROM PATCH MANAGEMENT,
CAN DEPLOY
AUTO SCALING FOR
THE HOLIDAY SEASON,
AND ENSURE
THE PROTECTION OF
THEIR CUSTOMER DATA.
DOESN'T THAT
SOUND BETTER?OKAY. LET'S
GO TO CLOUD SHELL
AND MODERNIZE
THIS VM RIGHT HERE
RIGHT NOW. WE BUILT
A SIMPLE
SCRIPT THAT TRIGGERS ANTHOS
MIGRATE TO BEGIN MODERNIZING
THAT ON
PREM VM TO
GOOGLE CLOUD AND AUTOMATICALLY
CONVERT IT TO
A CONTAINER IN KUBERNETES
ENGINE. ARE YOU READY?
LET'S EXECUTE THE
SCRIPT. OFF WE GO.
AND IT'S JUST THAT SIMPLE.
THIS
NEW STREAMLINED PROCESS
REPRESENTS A TREMENDOUS
SIMPLIFICATION
OF YOUR
MODERNIZATION JOURNEY.OKAY.
NOW LET'S SEE
THE RESULTS IN THE
CLOUD CONSOLE. NOW THAT
THIS PROCESS
HAS BEGUN, ANTHOS
MIGRATE WILL HAVE THIS
APP RUNNING
AGAIN IN JUST A
FEW MINUTES, REGARDLESS OF
HOW BIG THE DATA
SET IS. BUT WE DON'T
WANT TO KEEP YOU WAITING.
WE'VE KICKED
OFF AN EQUIVALENT PROCESS
JUST BEFORE WE CAME
ON STAGE. AS
YOU CAN SEE HERE
IN OUR CLOUD CONSOLE,
OUR eCOMMERCE SITE
THAT WAS RUNNING ON
A VM IS NOW RUNNING
IN A CONTAINER.
AND AS YOU CAN SEE,
THIS IS THE SAME APP,
BUT NOW OUR
CUSTOMERS GET ALL THE
BENEFITS OF ANTHOS AND
MANAGED KUBERNETES.
CONVERTING THAT VM
INTO A CONTAINER FREES
UP
OUR CUSTOMERS
FROM MANAGING INFRASTRUCTURE
AND LETS
THEM FOCUS ON DELIVERING
BUSINESS VALUE INSTEAD.
AND IT
MAKES MODERNIZATION EASIER THAN
YOU EVER THOUGHT POSSIBLE.
THIS IS
GAME CHANGING FOR
ANYONE WHO THOUGHT THEIR
VMs
MIGHT BE
IMPOSSIBLE TO MODERNIZE.
NOW, OVER TIME,
THIS SAME APPLICATION
HAS BEEN MODERNIZED
AS A
DYNAMIC MESH OF SERVICES
TALKING TO ONE ANOTHER.
MANAGING
SERVICE DRIVEN APPLICATIONS
CAN BE COMPLEX,
AND MODERN
SERVICES REQUIRE COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT ACCESS RESTRICTIONS.
FOR
INSTANCE, COMMERCE SERVICES
SUCH AS PROCUREMENT
AND ORDER
FULFILLMENT HAVE VERY
DIFFERENT POLICIES THAN
PAYMENT PROCESSING,
EVEN THOUGH BOTH REQUIRE
TIGHT CONTROLS AND AUDITS.
USING GOOGLE
CLOUD SERVICE MESH,
WE HAVE VISIBILITY INTO
ALL OF
THESE COMPONENTS AND WE
CAN FOCUS ON BUSINESS
AGILITY INSTEAD
OF ACCESS POLICIES.LET'S
LOOK A LITTLE BIT DEEPER
INTO THIS
APP'S DEPLOYMENT. THIS IS
STILL THE SAME APP,
AND IT'S GOT A
SHOPPING CART SERVICE WHICH YOU
CAN SEE HERE IN OUR TOPOLOGY VIEW.
LINES
ARE REPRESENTING PERMISSIONS
ACROSS THE SERVICES.
THIS SHOPPING
CART SERVICE IS BEING
ACCESSED BY SOME OF
OUR PARTNERS
RIGHT NOW.ON THE OTHER
HAND, THIS PAYMENT SERVICE
IS RESTRICTED TO
ONLY BE ACCESSED BY
THE SHOPPING CART SERVICE.
SINCE WE SHOWED YOU
THIS PRODUCT LAST YEAR,
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
ON SOME
INNOVATIVE ADVANCEMENTS,
INCLUDING GOOGLE CLOUD SERVICES
MESH'S ABILITY TO
DELIVER REAL TIME, IN
DEPTH TELEMETRY AND
SECURITY INSIGHTS. NOW
YOU CAN ASSESS
THE SECURITY POSTURE
OF
YOUR APPLICATIONS AND
MAKE PROACTIVE RECOMMENDATIONS
TO HELP MANAGE
RISK.LET'S TAKE A LOOK
AT THE PAYMENT SERVICE
AND HOW WE
CAN APPLY SECURITY POLICIES.
AS YOU CAN SEE HERE<
THERE'S A SECURITY
RECOMMENDATION FROM GOOGLE CLOUD
SERVICE MESH TO HELP IMPROVE THE
SECURITY POSTURE OF THE PAYMENT
SERVICE. THIS POLICY
RECOMMENDATION, ONCE APPLIED,
WILL AUTHORIZE
AND ENCRYPT TRAFFIC
BETWEEN THE PAYMENT
SERVICE AND
THE SHOPPING CART SERVICE.
THIS IS POLICY DRIVEN
DECISIONS
WITHOUT MODIFYING YOUR
BACK ENDS, WITHOUT
TOUCHING YOUR CODE.NOW,
LET'S GO TO THE
CLOUD SHELL AND ADD
THESE
CHANGES INTO OUR
ANTHOS CONFIG MANAGEMENT
REPOSITORY AND
THEN COMMIT THE
CHANGES. ANTHOS GIVES YOU
UNIFIED PROGRAMMATIC
APIs ACROSS ALL
OF YOUR DEPLOYMENTS.
SO NOW
THAT WE HAVE COMMITTED
THE CHANGES, THE NEW
DECLARATIVE
CONFIGURATION WILL BE
APPLIED ACROSS ALL
ENVIRONMENTS AT
ONCE. FOR APPLICATIONS
RUNNING ON ANTHOS,
CONTROLS ARE
IMPLEMENTED BY ANTHOS
WITHOUT ANY CHANGES
TO THE
APPLICATION, SO YOU
GET TO MANAGE GOVERNANCE
CONSISTENTLY, NO
MATTER WHERE YOUR
WORKLOADS RUN. YOU CAN
MOVE FAST AND
STAY AGILE WHILE IMPROVING
UPON YOUR SECURITY POSTURE.
EVERYTHING WE SHOWED YOU
TODAY IS NOT JUST
GCP AND ON PREM.
IN FACT, IF YOU LOOK AT THE
CONSOLE, YOU WILL SEE THERE ARE
THREE SERVICES RUNNING.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK
AT THE ADDRESS
OF ONE OF THEM.
IT'S
ACTUALLY RUNNING ON
ANOTHER PUBLIC CLOUD.
[APPLAUSE]
THIS IS REALLY
BIG. THANK YOU. WITH
ANTHOS, YOU RUN ANYWHERE,
AND NOT
ONLY THAT, YOU
CAN MANAGE SERVICES CONSISTENTLY
ON GOOGLE
CLOUD, ON PREM,
AND ON OTHER CLOUDS.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT
EYAL MEANT WHEN WE ANNOUNCED
THAT ANTHOS IS GOING MULTI CLOUD.
[APPLAUSE]
YES.SO WHAT DOES
THIS MEAN FOR YOU?
IF YOU'RE A DEVELOPER,
YOU GET TO
AVOID THE PAIN OF REWRITING
YOUR CODE JUST TO DEPLOY
TO A NEW
CLOUD. AS AN OPS
PERSON, YOU GET THE ABILITY
TO CONSISTENTLY
MANAGE YOUR APPS
WHEREVER THEY RUN.
IF YOU'RE
RUNNING A BUSINESS, YOU
GET LEVERAGE WHEN YOU'RE
NEGOTIATING A
CLOUD CONTRACT.AND THIS
ISN'T JUST ABOUT YOUR
OWN CODE.
IT EXTENDS TO SOFTWARE
FROM PARTNERS, ISVs, AND
THE OPEN
SOURCE COMMUNITY. HERE YOU
SEE US RUNNING ANTHOS
TO CONSISTENTLY
DEPLOY A CLOUD B CI/CD
SERVICE ACROSS ANY
ENVIRONMENT. BEFORE ANTHOS,
DEPLOYING TO MULTIPLE ENVIRONMENTS
MEANT CUSTOM CONFIGS FOR
EVERY ENVIRONMENT, TIME WASTED ON
OPERATIONAL OVERHEAD,
SECURITY AUDITS FOR
EACH NEW SERVICE,
AND MORE. NOW YOU
FINALLY HAVE A
CONSISTENT EXPERIENCE
TO FLEXIBLY
DEPLOY AND MANAGE
SERVICES RUNNING ON
GCP, IN YOUR OWN
DATA CENTER, AS WELL AS
ON OTHER CLOUDS. I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU, BUT I
THINK THAT'S PRETTY COOL.
[APPLAUSE]
ALL RIGHT. OVER
THE LAST YEAR, WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH MANY
CUSTOMERS ON
THEIR HYBRID AND
MULTI CLOUD TRANSFORMATIONS.
WE JUST SHOWED YOU A
LOT. LET'S TAKE A STEP BACK
AND LOOK AT WHAT WE SAW.
NUMBER
ONE, MODERNIZING YOUR
ON PREM WORKLOADS
IS EASIER
AND FASTER THAN EVER
BEFORE. TWO, MOST COMPANIES
ALREADY HAVE
A MULTI CLOUD AND
HYBRID STRATEGY, BUT ANTHOS
IS THE
ONLY PLATFORM THAT LETS
YOU ACTUALLY ACHIEVE THAT.
AND
THREE, WE UNDERSTAND
THAT EVERY TRANSFORMATION
IS DIFFERENT
AND GOOGLE WANTS
TO PARTNER WITH YOU
TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU ACHIEVE
ALL YOUR MODERNIZATION GOALS.
LET'S BRING YOUR CLOUD
AND YOUR SERVICES TO LIFE.
BACK TO YOU, THOMAS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> WOW,
JENNIFER. AMAZING JOB. WE'VE
SEEN SO MANY PARTNERS
WORKING WITH
US TO BRING US
SOLUTIONS TO CUSTOMERS TOGETHER.
ONE OF
THESE PARTNERS IS VM
WARE, A COMPANY THAT'S
USED BY
SO MANY ENTERPRISE CUSTOMERS,
AND IT'S MY GREAT
PRIVILEGE TO
WELCOME SANJAY PUNAN,
CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER
OF VM WARE TO GOOGLE NEXT. SANJAY.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THANKS, THOMAS.
>> SANJAY,
GREAT TO HAVE
YOU AT NEXT.
IN BETWEEN
WIDESPREAD ADOPTION OF
KUBERNETES SINCE ITS INCEPTION,
BOTH OF
OUR COMPANIES ARE
COMMITTED TO DELIVERING HYBRID
CLOUD SOLUTIONS
BASED ON OPEN
SOURCE TECHNOLOGIES THAT
GOOGLE CREATED
WHICH ARE ESSENTIAL
TO MODERN APP DEVELOPMENTS.
CAN YOU PROVIDE
US WITH MORE DETAIL
ON HOW OPEN SOURCE
TECHNOLOGIES LIKE
KUBERNETES ARE PART
OF VMWARE'S STRATEGY?
>> YEAH, I
WILL, THOMAS. LET
ME FIRST SAY CONGRATULATIONS
ON YOUR ROLE. THOMAS
AND I GREW UP IN
THE SAME TOWN IN BANGLOR,
AND WE WENT
TO RIVAL SCHOOLS. I
SPENT EIGHT YEARS COMPETING
AGAINST HIM WHEN
I WAS AT SAP
AND ORACLE. I'M JUST HAPPY
TO BE ON
THE STAGE PARTNERING WITH YOU,
FINALLY. SO THAT'S GREAT.
>> THANK YOU:
[ Applause]
>> AND HE'S
GOING TO DO GREAT
THINGS FOR GOOGLE CLOUD.
ON YOUR QUESTION
TO KUBERNETES, I THINK
THE WORLD IS STARTING
TO REALIZE
IT IS A WORLD
OF CONTAINERS AND VMs
AND WE
HAVE EMBRACED KUBERNETES
BIG TIME AT VMWARE.
WE ACQUIRED
A COMPANY HEPTIO THAT
WAS STARTED BY SOME
OF THE FOUNDERS
OF KUBERNETES AND NOW
WITH GOOGLE HAVE BECOME
ONE OF
THE TOP CONTRIBUTORS
TO KUBERNETES. AND WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS
TAKING YOUR NEW NAME, ANTHOS,
INTEGRATING IT WITH ESSENTIAL
PKS, WHICH IS A NEW
NAME FOR HEPTIO, AND ARE GOING TO
DELIVER A UNIFIED SOLUTION THAT
WILL BE
SUPPORTED BY
VMWARE AND GOOGLE.
SECONDLY, WE'RE
ALSO GOING TO
SUPPORT ANTHOS ON VSPHERE,
OUR LEADING HYPERVISOR
AND ALSO ON ESSENTIAL
PKS. SO OUR DESIRES
TO BRING FOR
ALL OF YOU ENTERPRISE
CUSTOMERS THE BEST OF A
VIRTUAL MACHINE AND KUBERNETES
CONTAINERS TOGETHER
WITH THIS COLLABORATION.
>> THANK YOU, SANJAY.
A KEY COMPONENT OF
THE HYBRID CLOUD IS NETWORKING,
ALL THE
WAY FROM THE BRANCH
OFFICE TO THE CLOUD.
WHAT ARE WE
DOING TOGETHER WITH SD
VAN AND SERVICE MESH?
>> YEAH. YOU KNOW,
QUIETLY, MANY OF YOU
MAY NOT THINK OF
VMWARE IN A
NETWORKING SPACE, FOR THE
LAST FIVE OR SIX YEARS,
SINCE WE
ACQUIRED NICIRA, WE'VE
BECOME THE LEADER
IN SOFTWARE
DEFINED NETWORKING AND
OUR VISION HAS BEEN
TO TAKE NSX
THE PRODUCT FROM THE
DATA CENTER TO THE CLOUD
AND TO
THE BRANCH. WE ALSO
ACQUIRED, ABOUT 18 MONTHS,
A REALLY HOT
COMPANY CALLED VELO CLOUD,
AND VELO CLOUD HAS
BECOME NOW, IN
GARTNER'S SORT OF RANKING,
THE TOP IN SD WIN.
IT'S SORT OF
LIKE THE NAME SAYS, VELOCITY
AND CLOUD. IT DOES THINGS
REALLY FAST
AND SIMPLE. SO WITH
SIMPLE THINGS LIKE ZERO
TOUCH PROVISIONING,
A SINGLE CLICK,
DYNAMIC MULTIPATH PROVISIONING,
WE ARE
ABLE TO BASICALLY
INTEGRATE NOW TO GCP
SO THAT
MANY OF YOU FOLKS
WHO HAVE REMOTE OFFICES
AND BRANCH
OFFICES AND RETAIL AND
BANKS AND OTHER PLACES
CAN GET THE
BEST BENEFITS OF VELO CLOUD,
INTEGRATIVE NATIVELY INTO GCP,
AND NOW ALL OF YOUR APPLICATIONS
IN THE BRANCH OFFICES
JUST WORK FASTER.
>> AND YOU'RE
A SENIOR EXECUTIVE
OF THE DELL FAMILY.
WHERE DOES
VMWARE AND THE BROADER
DELL FAMILY SEE OPPORTUNITIES
IN WORKING MORE CLOSELY WITH GCP?
>> YEAH, AS
YOU KNOW, DELL HAS
NOW, HAS GONE PUBLIC,
IS ONE OF
THE LEADING HARDWARE PROVIDERS
OF A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
AREAS, SERVIER
STORAGE, INFRASTRUCTURE. MANY
OF THE BENEFITS
WE TALKED
ABOUT ANTHROS RUNNING
ON VSPHERE WILL EXTEND
TO
WHAT'S CALLED
HYPERCONVERSION INFRASTRUCTURE,
VX RAIL
AND VMWARE'S INVESTMENT
IN SOFTWARE DEFINED STORAGE
IS NOW NUMBER
ONE IN THAT CATEGORY,
SO YOU'LL GET ALL
THOSE BENEFITS WITH
DELL HARDWARE. DELL ALSO
HAS A GREAT ASSET
CALLED BOOMI, WHICH
HAS BECOME A CLOUD
BASED DATA INTEGRATION LEADER.
WE ARE INTEGRATING
THAT WITH APOGEE, THAT's
PART OF THE GOOGLE FAMILY,
TO BRING
THE BEST OF DATA
INTEGRATION AND API MANAGEMENT,
WHICH IS
WHAT PEOPLE WANT TODAY
IN THIS INTEGRATION WORLD.
AND THEN
ON OUR CLIENT SIDE,
WE'VE BEEN QUIETLY INNOVATING
WITH WORK
SPACE ONE THAT
CAME FROM VMWARE'S ACQUISITION
OF AIRWATCH. WE'VE BEEN
DOING A LOT OF GOOD
STUFF WITH YOU IN
ANDROID AND CHROMEBOOK,
WHERE WE'RE NOW
THE LEADER IN WHAT'S
CALLED UNIFIED ENDPOINTMANAGEMENT,
BUT WE'RE GOING TO EXTEND
THAT NOW TO GOOGLE CLOUD IDENTITY
ENGINE SO WE
CAN BRING ALL THAT
CONTEXT AWARE DATA INTO
GOOGLE CLOUD
IDENTITY ENGINE. SO A
LOT OF THINGS THAT
WE ARE LOOKING FORWARD
TO COLLABORATING WITH YOU ALREADY
DONE AND MORE TO COME.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH, SANJAY.
>> THANK YOU,
THOMAS. AND CONGRATULATION.
[APPLAUSE]
>> SO WHEN
WE BUILT ANTHOS, WE
WORKED WITH A NUMBER OF
HARDWARE COMPANIES
TO ALLOW OUR
CUSTOMERS WHO ARE DEPLOYING
IN A
HYBRID ARCHITECTURE TO USE
THEIR PREFERRED HARDWARE STACK
TO RUN
ANTHOS. WE'RE ALSO
GRATEFUL FOR A PARTNERSHIP
WITH INTEL
WHO HAS BUILT
A REFERENCE ARCHITECTURE
FOR ANTHOS
TO MAKE IT EASY
FOR CUSTOMERS TO DEPLOY
OUR WORK
LOADS ON ANTHOS
ON THIS REFERENCE CONFIGURATION.
FINALLY, WE
RECOGNIZE THAT YOU
WANT SOLUTIONS PARTNERS,
AND WE
WORK WITH A
NUMBER OF SOLUTION PROVIDERS
WHO COMPLEMENT
OUR TECHNOLOGY AND
THAT OF OUR PARTNERS,
AS WELL
AS SERVICES PARTNERS WHO
CAN RUN AND MANAGE
SERVICES FOR YOU
ON ANTHOS. TO HEAR
FROM A CUSTOMER WHO
HAS BEEN
USING ANTHOS IN
EARLY ACCESS, PLEASE WELCOME
RATNAKAR
LAVU, CHIEF TECHNOLOGY
OFFICER AND SENIOR
EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT OF KOHL'S, A LEADING
AMERICAN RETAILER. RATNAKAR?
>> HI, THOMAS.
>> RATNAKER, WELCOME
TO NEXT. NOW, AS A LEADING
RETAILER FOR OVER 50 YEARS,
TELL US
ABOUT HOW YOU
AND MICHELLE, YOUR CEO,
ARE LOOKING
AT A STRATEGY FOR
THE NEXT 50 YEARS.
Ratnakar Lavu: FIRST
OF ALL, CONGRATULATIONS
ON YOUR NEW ROLE.
AS YOU KNOW,
THOMAS, YOU AND I HAVE
WORKED A LONG TIME TOGETHER.
SO AS A
RETAILER, WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN
FOCUSED ON THE CUSTOMER.
CUSTOMER FIRST.
IN TODAY'S DIGITAL
AGE AND DIGITAL TRANSFORMATION,
OUR
CUSTOMERS ARE EXPECTING SEAMLESS,
FRICTIONLESS EXPERIENCES.
SO THAT THEN
TRANSLATED AS IN TO THINKING
ABOUT THE WAY WE WORK.
WE WANTED
TO BE MORE AGILE,
MORE NIMBLE. THAT THEN
TRANSLATED INTO HOW
WE DO THINGS. SO
WHY SHOULD WE SET UP
INFRASTRUCTURE AND
OTHER THINGS LIKE WE
USED TO DO BEFORE.
SO WE ARE
NOW LEVERAGING OUR HYBRID
CLOUD, SO AS PART
OF THE HYBRID
CLOUD STRATEGY, THE ABILITY
TO LEVERAGE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
IN THE
CLOUD, THE APPLICATIONS IN
THE CLOUD TO BRING
ALL THESE
EXPERIENCES THAT OUR
CUSTOMERS ARE DEMANDING.
AND BY THE
WAY, GOOGLE ANTHOS IS THE
ONE THAT WE CHOSE.
>> WITH
ALL THE DIFFERENT
CLOUD PROVIDERS OUT THERE,
WHY DID YOU
CHOOSE GOOGLE AS YOUR PRIMARY
CLOUD PARTNER?
>> AS YOU KNOW,
THOMAS, RETAIL IS IN THE
MIDST OF MAJOR TRANSFORMATION.
SO AS A
RETAILER, WE NEEDED TO
INNOVATE. WE ALSO NEEDED
TO BECOME
MORE ENGINEERING FOCUSED.
AND GUESS WHAT.
GOOGLE HAS
THAT SAME DNA, AN ENGINEERING
FOCUS, DRIVING INNOVATION,
THAT REALLY KIND
OF BLENDED US TOGETHER
IN TERMS OF THIS PARTNERSHIP.
AND BY
THE WAY, I'M SUPER
EXCITED ABOUT THAT.
>> THANK YOU.
WHAT ARE SOME
OF THE BENEFITS
THAT YOU'VE SEEN
AS YOU'VE MIGRATED MORE
WORKLOADS TO THE CLOUD?
WHAT DID YOU
DECIDE TO KEEP? WHAT DID
YOU DECIDE TO MOVE?
>> YEAH. SO
THE BIG BENEFITS IS
AS A RETAILER, OUR BIG
THING IS,
IS THE HOLIDAY
SEASON, BLACK FRIDAY, TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF VOLUME.
SO WHAT WE NEEDED
TO DO BEFORE THE CLOUD
WAS WE NEEDED
TO GET ALL THIS
CAPACITY, AND THAT CAPACITY
USED TO SIT IDLE
FOR ABOUT NINE MONTHS
OF THE YEAR. SO THE
CLOUD ACTUALLY
ENABLED US TO SCALE
TO THAT CAPACITY DURING
THE HOLIDAY SEASON.
SO BIG BENEFIT FOR US.
AND IN TERMS OF THE
HYBRID CLOUD, IT
ALSO GAVE US THE
ABILITY TO BE MORE AGILE
USING DEV
OPS AND ALSO TO
MOVE APPLICATIONS AND CHANGE
APPLICATIONS MUCH
FASTER. SO THESE ARE
SOME OF THE KEY
BENEFITS THAT
WE HAVE SEEN WITH
THE CLOUD.NOW, WHEN IT
COMES TO HOW
DID WE DECIDE WHAT
TO ACTUALLY MOVE AND
TRANSFORM TO
THE CLOUD, WE DID
AN EXTENSIVE AND EXHAUSTIVE
ANALYSIS OF
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE AND
OUR APPLICATIONS, AND WE
BROKE THEM INTO
THREE PARTS. ONE IS
ARE THEY CLOUD READY?
HENCE, LIFT AND
SHIFT. ARE THEY  DO
THEY NEED TO BE RE
DESIGNED FOR THE
CLOUD? AND SO WE'RE
IN THE PROCESS OF
WORKING ON
MANY APPLICATIONS TO MAKE
THEM CLOUD READY. AND
THE THIRD
IS SHOULD WE RETIRE
SOMETHING BECAUSE IT'S NO
LONGER IMPORTANT IN
THIS NEW WORLD. AND
WE'VE BEEN ON THIS
JOURNEY FOR THREE
YEARS, AND I CAN
TELL YOU WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT
WHAT WE ARE
SEEING RIGHT NOW.
>> GREAT. HOW
DO YOU MEASURE
SUCCESS WITH THE TRANSFORMATION?
Ratnakar Lavu: SUCCESS
IS, AGAIN, BACK
TO THE CUSTOMER.
IT'S ABOUT
THE CUSTOMER ENGAGEMENT
AND THE SALES.
AND LAST
BLACK FRIDAY, WE
RAN KOHL'S.COM AND MOBILE,
OUR MOBILE
APPLICATIONS AND MOBILE WEB,
ON THE GOOGLE CLOUD.
AND WHAT I
CAN TELL YOU IS
WE SUSTAINED THE PEAK LOAD.
WE ACTUALLY
HAD THE BEST
RESPONSE TIME IN TERMS
OF THE
EXPERIENCE FOR OUR CUSTOMERS
AND WE HAD TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF
SALES. SO I'M REALLY
HAPPY WITH THAT.
>>
CONGRATULATIONS,
RATNAKAR.
[Applause]
THANK YOU FOR THE
WORK YOU AND YOUR
TEAM ARE DOING WITH US.
>> THANK YOU.
[APPLAUSE]
>> SO LET'S
STEP BACK A MINUTE NOW
AND LOOK AT GOOGLE'S VISION
FOR CLOUD
COMPUTING. NOW, WE SEE
INDUSTRIES AROUND THE WORLD
BEING TRANSFORMED
WITH DIGITAL TECHNOLOGY,
WHETHER THAT'S HOSPITALS
WANTING TO
CHANGE HOW THEY DELIVER
PATIENT CARE USING DIGITAL,
THE WAY
THAT RETAILERS WANT
TO OFFER NEW EXPERIENCES
FOR CUSTOMERS,
OR FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS
WANT TO ATTRACT CUSTOMERS
IN NEW WAYS.
WE AT GOOGLE WANT
TO DELIVER THREE IMPORTANT THINGS
TO HELP
CUSTOMERS ON THIS
JOURNEY. FIRST, GLOBAL SCALE
DISTRIBUTED
INFRASTRUCTURE. SECOND, A
SUITE OF DIGITAL
TRANSFORMATION
SOLUTIONS. AND
THIRD, SPECIFIC SOLUTIONS
USING
GOOGLE'S ADVANCED TECHNOLOGIES
FOR SPECIFIC INDUSTRIES.
NOW, FOR
GLOBAL SCALE
DISTRIBUTED INFRASTRUCTURE,
WE LOOK
AT BUILDING OUT CAPABILITIES
IN GOOGLE CLOUD, BRINGING
THE  BROADENING
THE NUMBER OF REGIONS
AROUND THE WORLD TO
WHICH WE DELIVER
THAT, TAKING THAT OUT TO
THE CLOUD EDGE; FOR EXAMPLE,
FOR CUSTOMERS
IN GAMING, IN
MEDIA, IN STREAMING, OR
DISTRIBUTING OUR
BROAD NETWORK EDGE
TO BRING COMPUTING
CLOSER TO YOU.
AND NOW WITH ANTHOS, WE
CAN BRING IT ALL THE
WAY INTO YOUR
DATA CENTER WITH HYBRID
CLOUD OR ON MULTIPLE CLOUDS.
FOR A
PLATFORM FOR
DIGITAL TRANSFORMATION, WE'VE
BUILDING CAPABILITY
TO OFFER FIVE IMPORTANT
SOLUTIONS FOR CUSTOMERS:
THE ABILITY
TO MANAGE DATA AT
SCALE; TO BUILD AND
MODERNIZE APPLICATION
WORKLOADS; TO DO
ANALYSIS TO IDENTIFY
PATTERNS IN YOUR
DATA AND MAKE BETTER BUSINESS
DECISIONS AS ORGANIZATIONS;
TO USE
GOOGLE'S AI AND
ML TECHNOLOGY ADVANCES;
AND TO
COLLABORATE WITH OTHER
PEOPLE IN THE ORGANIZATION
OR OUTSIDE THE
BOUNDARIES OF THE ORGANIZATION
IN PROFOUND NEW WAYS.
WE'RE ALSO
BROADENING THIS PLATFORM
TO ALLOW PARTNERS
TO COMPLIMENT
OUR PLATFORM. AND
WE HAVE SOME VERY
IMPORTANT
ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY
WITH PARTNERS.
FINALLY, WE'RE BUILDING
OUT UNIQUE CAPABILITY
FOR SPECIFIC INDUSTRIES
WHICH HELP
COMPANIES IN THESEINDUSTRIES
TO USE GOOGLE'S TECHNOLOGY
ADVANCES TO TRANSFORM THEMSELVES.
THESE INCLUDE ORGANIZATIONS
IN HEALTHCARE, IN RETAIL,
IN MEDIA, FINANCIAL SERVICES
AND OTHER INDUSTRIES. NOW,
WE'RE INCREDIBLY PROUD
OF THE MOMENTUM
WE HAVE IN THE
LARGEST COMPANIES ON EARTH.
NINE OF THE
TOP TEN RETAILERS, SEVEN OF
THE TOP TEN MEDIA COMPANIES,
AND
LEADERS IN VIRTUALLY
EVERY INDUSTRY HAVE
CHOSEN GOOGLE
CLOUD TO HELP
THEM ON THEIR DIGITAL
TRANSFORMATION JOURNEY.
NOW, THE REASON
THEY'VE CHOSEN US
IS BECAUSE OF
THE CAPABILITIES THAT WE
PROVIDE. ONE OF OUR
MOST IMPORTANT INDUSTRIES
IS HEALTHCARE, AND WE'RE GRATEFUL
FOR LIFE SCIENCES COMPANIES,
PATIENT CARE PROVIDERS, INSURANCE
COMPANIES AND OTHERS WHO
HAVE USED GOOGLE CLOUD.
WE'RE SUPER
EXCITED TODAY TO
ANNOUNCE A NUMBER
OF NEW COMPANIES
THAT ARE USING GOOGLE
CLOUD TO DELIVER HEALTHCARE
IN NEW
WAYS. ONE OF
THESE CUSTOMERS IS PHILLIPS,
AND IT'S
MY GREAT PRIVILEGE
TO WELCOME ALTNA DOSHI,
GROUP CHIEF INFORMATION
OFFICER OF PHILLIPS, TO GOOGLE
CLOUD NEXT. ALPNA?
[APPLAUSE]
>> HOW ARE YOU, THOMAS?
>> THANK YOU
FOR COMING. IT'S
WONDERFUL TO HAVE YOU.
TELL US ABOUT
THE WORK THAT PHILLIPS IS DOING
GLOBALLY IN HEALTHCARE.
>> ABSOLUTELY. FIRST
OF ALL, WHAT A PLEASURE
TO HEAR ABOUT ANTHOS.
YOU KEPT IT
AS A WELL PRESERVED SECRET,
SO HUGE CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THAT WAS
MUSIC TO MY EARS. AT
PHILLIPS, OUR MISSION AND VISION
IS TO BE
SURE THAT WE IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF THREE BILLION PEOPLE
PER YEAR BY 2030.
AND IT'S A TARGET THAT WE
WANT TO ACHIEVE WITH HELP OF,
OF COURSE, PARTNERS
LIKE GOOGLE AND MANY
OF THE OTHER PARTNERS
THAT YOU
HAVE ALSO MENTIONED. AND,
INDEED, WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE TRENDS
IN THE HEALTHCARE TECHNOLOGY
SECTOR, THEN IT IS
ABOUT DIGITALIZATION.
TO BEGIN WITH,
THE CUSTOMER CENTRICITY
IS VERY,
VERY IMPORTANT. YOU NEED
TO KNOW THE PATIENTS.
YOU NEED TO
KNOW THE DOCTORS, THE
CLINICIANS. SO THAT IS
AN IMPORTANT
ASPECT IN THE
HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY. AND
WE ARE FACING
ALL OF THESE CHALLENGES
IN THIS INDUSTRY WHILE
THE TRANSFORMATION
IN TECHNOLOGY AROUND
US BY THE
WORLDWIDE INDUSTRIAL
OR, YOU KNOW,
INDUSTRY, IOT DEVICES,
MACHINE LEARNING AND
AI ARE COMING UP
RIGHT BEHIND US, RIGHT?
SO FOR US
IT IS IMPORTANT TO MEET
THAT QUADRUPLE IN, WHICH IS
PATIENT CARE,
BETTER HEALTH OUTCOMES.
AND ALL THE ASPECTS
WHERE GIVING
HEALTHCARE SERVICES SHOULD
BE AFFORDABLE.
>> HOW DO YOU
SEE DELIVERING PATIENT CARE
TO BILLIONS OF PEOPLE,
AND HOW
DOES CLOUD TECHNOLOGY REALLY
HELP YOU TO DELIVER
TO
THAT LAST MILE
TO THAT PATIENT?
>> ABSOLUTELY. AND
IF I LOOK BACK, WE ARE
A 127 YEAR OLD COMPANY,
AND I'M
SURE THERE ARE MANY
ENTERPRISES OF THAT NATURE.
SO WHEN I
SEE GOOGLE, FOR EXAMPLE,
I MEAN, I'M PROBABLY
THE NEXT
GENERATION CIO, YOU
KNOW, NEXT NEXT, RIGHT?
SO WHEN I
LOOK AT IT, IN PHILLIPS
WE HAVE A HUGE
OUR STRATEGY
IS TO HAVE
THE DIGITAL TRANSFORMATION
FOR THE
LEGACY LANDSCAPE. NOW, WHAT
WE HAVE ALREADY DONE
IS TAKEN
2,000 APPLICATIONS AND PUT
THEM ON THE CLOUD.
NOW, THESE WERE
INITIALLY TIER 2 APPLICATIONS.
NOW, WHERE WE WANT
TO FOCUS ON
AND WHAT I BELIEVE THIS
MORNING I HEARD FROM SUNDAR,
JENNIFER, AND
YOU ALSO MENTIONING
ABOUT IT IS THE
WHOLE ASPECT OF
NOT ONLY HYBRID CLOUD
BUT ALSO CYBER SECURITY
PLAYS A BIG ROLE. AND
SO WHAT IS RUNNING IN MY
MIND RIGHT NOW IS TIER 1.
WE TALK ABOUT THE
ERPs, THE SAP BASIS WHICH
ALL OF OUR LARGE COMPANY AND
HEALTHCARE DOMAIN
IS WORKING. TO US,
QUALITY, AVAILABILITY, AND
SECURITY ARE
PROBABLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT THREE CRITERIA.
AND THAT'S WHERE
I LOOK AT, YOU KNOW,
CLOUD PLAYING A HUGE ROLE,
BECAUSE WE
CAN'T LIVE WITH
THE LEGACY DATA CENTERS
WHERE SERVICE ASSURANCE
IS A PAIN. YOU
NEED TO MOVE TO CLOUD
ON
DEMAND QUICK AND
MAKE IT HAPPEN.
>> WHERE DO
YOU SEE AI AND ML HELPING YOU
IN YOUR TRANSFORMATION?
>> WELL, WHAT I
NOTICE IS THAT, YOU
KNOW, AI ALLOWS THE ANALYSIS
AND DECISION MAKING
TO BE QUITE DIFFERENT
THAN WHAT US ARE
CAPABLE OF
WITHOUT THE MACHINE
LEARNING AND AI CAPABILITIES.
SO TO US,
WHEN WE ARE DOING
THESE NON INVASIVE PROCEEDURES
IN THE CLINICS,
THEN ALL OF THE DATA
SETS THAT WE CAN HAVE
AS A
REFERENCE ON WHICH MACHINE
LEARNING AND ALL OF
THESE DATA BEING
LOADED UP IN THE
CLOUD AND THEN MACHINE LEARNING
AND AI
ALGORITHMS BEING APPLIED FOR
BETTER DECISION INSIGHT TO
THE DOCTORS, PYHSICIANS,
ET CETERA. SO EVEN
AS A PATIENT, WE
ARE WELL INFORMED
OF WHAT IS GOING
ON. THE SELF CARE BECOMES
POSSIBLE. SO TO
US, IN FACT, THE
ASPECT THAT GOOGLE IS, INDEED,
LOOKING AT
CLOUD AND A COMBINATION
OF MACHINE LEARNING AND
AI IS ACTUALLY
REALLY GOOD BECAUSE THAT
GIVES US A WAY NOT
ONLY TO LEARN
FROM YOU ALL AND DEPEND
ON YOU ALL BUT ALSO
ALLOW FOR OUR
QUADRUPLE AIM, AS I MENTIONED,
TO HAPPEN.
>> THANK YOU,
ALPNA, FOR YOUR AMAZING
MISSION AT PHILLIPS AND
FOR YOUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH US TO
SERVE PEOPLE AROUND THE
WORLD
WITH BETTER
HEALTHCARE.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU FOR COMING.
[APPLAUSE]
RETAIL IS ANOTHER
INDUSTRY THAT'S GOING
THROUGH MAJOR TRANSFORMATION,
AND WE
AT GOOGLE HAVE BEEN
VERY FORTUNATE TO WORK
WITH MANY
OF THE LEADING
RETAILERS AROUND THE WORLD.
TODAY AT GOOGLE
NEXT, WE ARE PLEASED
TO ANNOUNCE THAT SOME BRANDS
THAT ALL OF
YOU ARE FAMILIAR WITH
HAVE CHOSEN US TO TRANSFORM
HOW THEY
DELIVER GREAT NEW
EXPERIENCES TO CONSUMERS AROUND
THE WORLD.NOW,
FINANCIAL SERVICES IS
A INDUSTRY THAT GOOGLE
HAS HAD A
LONG HISTORY OF COLLABORATION
WITH. WE'VE HAD MANY
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS
RUNNING ON GOOGLE
CLOUD AND USING
GOOGLE CLOUD
TO DELIVER GREAT NEW
SERVICES TO THEIR CONSUMERS.
AT GOOGLE
CLOUD NEXT, WE
ARE VERY PLEASED TO
ANNOUNCE TWO
IMPORTANT NEW CUSTOMERS,
CHASE AND ANZIET BANK.
IT IS
NOW MY GREAT PRIVILEGE
TO WELCOME REGGIE CHAMBERS,
MANAGING
DIRECTOR AND
CHIEF ADMINISTRATIVE
OFFICER OF
CHASE CONSUMER BANKING, TO
GOOGLE CLOUD NEXT TO
TALK ABOUT
HOW WE'RE WORKING
TOGETHER TO TRANSFORM
COMMUNITY BANKING.
REGGIE, WELCOME TO GOOGLE
CLOUD NEXT.
[APPLAUSE]
THANK YOU FOR COMING,
REGGIE. TELL US A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT YOURSELF,
YOUR ROLE AT
CHASE, AND WHAT YOU'RE DOING TO
TRANSFORM COMMUNITY BANKING.
>> FANTASTIC. WELL,
THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR HAVING ME HERE.
I COULD NOT BE
MORE EXCITED TO TALK ABOUT
THE THINGS WE ARE DOING
TO TRANSFORM
THE BANKING INDUSTRY, AS
THEY ARE VERY MUCH
ALIGNED WITH MY
PERSONAL PASSION IN LIFE
WHICH IS TO HELP OTHERS.
ALL YOU NEED TO
KNOW ABOUT ME IS THAT I'M
A HUSBAND AND A FATHER OF
TWO BEAUTIFUL CHILDREN,
MADISON AND MYLES, AND
LIKE SO MANY OF YOU,
I AM PASSIONATE
ABOUT TRYING TO MAKE
A DIFFERENCE IN THE WORLD
AND LEAVING IT
A BIT BETTER THAN I
FOUND IT AND SO THAT
THE WORLD CAN BE
A BIT BETTER GOING FORWARD
FOR OUR KIDS, OUR FAMILIES,
AND OUR
COMMUNITIES. THIS IS
AN AMAZING COUNTRY,
ONE WHERE
MY FAMILY HAS GONE
FROM BEING SLAVES, SHARECROPPERS,
FARMERS IN THE
SEGREGATED SOUTH, TO BEING
TO ATTENDING TOP UNIVERSITIES,
SERVING A
PRESIDENT IN THE WHITE
HOUSE, AND NOW STANDING
IN FRONT
OF YOU ALL REPRESENTING
AN AMAZING INSTITUTION
LIKE
JP MORGAN CHASE.
[APPLAUSE]
YOU KNOW, WE ARE FORTUNATE
TO LIVE IN THE LAND OF
OPPORTUNITY, WHERE A STORY LIKE
MINE IS POSSIBLE, BUT WHEN
WE LOOK ACROSS AMERICA
TODAY, WE REALIZE THAT'S
NOT TRUE FOR EVERYONE. FOR MANY,
THE DOORS OF OPPORTUNITY
ARE CLOSED.
THEY DON'T HAVE A
FAIR SHOT. AND WHAT WE
WANT TO DO HERE AT
CHASE IS WE
WANT TO WORK ALONGSIDE
PARTNERS LIKE GOOGLE TO
CHANGE THAT OUTCOME
A BIT. WE ARE
FORTUNATE TO HAVE GREAT
RESOURCES AS
GOOGLE AND AS
CHASE TO ADDRESS THIS
OPPORTUNITY GAP, AND
THAT'S WHAT WE WANT TO
DO TODAY.SO AT CHASE, I
AM FORTUNATE
TO BE A PART
OF THE LEADERSHIP TEAM
THAT IS
INNOVATING AROUND HOW WE
CAN BETTER SERVE THE
COMMUNITIES WE
ARE IN. WE SERVE
OUR CUSTOMERS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WITH MORE THAN
135,000 EMPLOYEES AND MORE THAN
5,000 BRANCHES. AND WHAT WE'RE
SEEING TODAY WITH OUR CUSTOMERS
IS THEY WANT MORE
THAN JUST HAVING A
TRANSACTIONAL RELATIONSHIP
WITH US. THEY
WANT TO HAVE A
PARTNER WHO
CAN PROVIDE ADVICE AT
LIFE MOMENTS WHEN THEY
NEED US THE
MOST. AND WE WANT TO
BE THAT GO TO PARTNER,
TOGETHER WITH
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS IN
GOOGLE, TO DO
JUST THAT, AND
WE CAN CHANGE THE
BANK BRANCH MODEL OF THE
FUTURE IN ORDER
TO PROVIDE MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THE COMMUNITIES WE SERVE.
>> CAN YOU GIVE THE AUDIENCE
SOME EXAMPLES OF HOW YOU'RE
WORKING TO MAKE THIS REAL?
>> ABSOLUTELY. I'M
EXCITED TO DO THAT. SO YEAH,
WE HAVE A UNIQUE VISION
FOR THE BANK
BRANCH MODEL OF THE
FUTURE. WE WANT OUR BRANCHES
TO BE DESTINATIONS,
WHERE PEOPLE CAN GO
TO GET THE ADVICE
THEY NEED TO
LEAD A FINANCIALLY HEALTHY
LIFE. WE ALSO WANT
TO HAVE
BRANCHES THAT ARE INNOVATION
CENTERS, WHERE YOU CAN
HAVE THE
LATEST TECHNOLOGY AND
INNOVATIVE COMMUNITY PROGRAMMING
TO REALLY
DELIVER THE NEXT VALUE
PROPOSITION FOR OUR CUSTOMERS
AND OUR CLIENTS. IMAGINE A
PLACE WHERE YOU CAN GO TO LEARN
HOW TO CODE, LEARN HOW TO SET
UP A SMALL BUSINESS, LEARN HOW
TO DO YOUR TAXES, LEARN HOW
TO GET THE JOB INTERVIEWING SKILLS
THAT YOU NEED SO
THAT YOU CAN TAKE IT
TO THE NEXT LEVEL FOR YOU
AND YOUR FAMILY. AND
THAT'S WHAT WE WANT TO
DO IS BRING THOSE SORT
OF DATA
INSIGHTS AND TECHNOLOGY
TO THAT GAME.
AND TOGETHER
WITH PARTNERS LIKE GOOGLE,
WE'RE GOING TO TURN
THAT DREAM INTO
A REALITY. SO WE
ARE EXCITED TO ANNOUNCE
THAT WE
HAVE CHOSEN HARLEM, ONE
OF OUR NATION'S MOST
HISTORIC COMMUNITIES, TO
LAUNCH THIS NEW BRANCH
BANK BRANCH MODEL
OF THE FUTURE,
AND WE'RE EXCITED TO
TELL YOU GUYS MORE
ABOUT IT
IN THE COMING WEEKS
AND MONTHS AHEAD.
>> REGGIE, ALONG WITH
OUR TEAM AT GOOGLE,
I'M SUPER PLEASED TO PARTNER
WITH YOU ON
SUCH A HISTORIC MISSION.
WE'RE SO PROUD THAT
WE CAN HELP
YOU AS A TECHNOLOGY
PARTNER ON THIS NOBLE MISSION
THAT YOU
AND CHASE ARE
EMBARKING ON.
>> THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
[APPLAUSE]
>> SIMILAR TO WHAT WE'RE
DOING IN RETAIL AND FINANCIAL
SERVICES AND HEALTHCARE,
WE'RE ALSO TRANSFORMING
MANUFACTURING, HELPING
ORGANIZATIONS OPTIMIZE THE
SUPPLY CHAIN, THEIR WAREHOUSES,
THEIR DISTRIBUTION SYSTEMS,
AND WE'RE VERY
PLEASED AT
GOOGLE CLOUD NEXT THAT
A NUMBER OF ADDITIONAL
MANUFACTURING BRANDS,
A FEW OF THEM
HERE, HAVE CHOSEN US
TO BE
THEIR STRATEGIC PARTNER
ON DIGITAL TRANSFORMATION.
GOOGLE ALSO
HAS A LONG
HISTORY IN TELECOMMUNICATIONS,
MEDIA AND
ENTERTAINMENT. NINE OF THE
TOP TEN MEDIA COMPANIES
IN THE WORLD
USE US TO HELP
THEM ADD GREAT DIGITAL CONTENT,
CREATE
DYNAMIC CATALOGS, USE
OUR STREAMING INFRASTRUCTURE
TO DISTRIBUTE THEM,
AND ALLOW THEM TO
BUILD NEW MODELS FOR BUSINESS
LIKE DIRECT
TO CONSUMER. THESE ARE
SOME OF THE CUSTOMERS
WHO CHOOSE US,
AND AT GOOGLE CLOUD
NEXT, WE ARE VERY PLEASED
TO ANNOUNCE
SOME ADDITIONAL WINS OF MEDIA
AND ENTERTAINMENT COMPANIES,
AS WELL
AS TELECOMMUNICATION PARTNERS
WHO HAVE CHOSEN US
TO HELP THEM ON
THAT JOURNEY TO THE
CLOUD.FINALLY, WE HAVE A
LONG COMMITMENT
TO THE PUBLIC SECTOR.
WE'LL WORK WITH STATE
GOVERNMENTS,
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES, AND EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS. THIS
IS JUST A TINY
SEGMENT OF THE
MANY CUSTOMERS IN PUBLIC
SECTOR USE GOOGLE CLOUD,
AND WE HAVE
MANY MORE NEW CUSTOMERS,
SOME OF WHICH
I'VE LISTED HERE
FOR YOU TO SEE.OUR
WORK IN THESE INDUSTRIES
WOULD NOT
BE COMPLETE IF WE DIDN'T
BUILD ENTERPRISE CAPABILITY.
AND WE AT
GOOGLE CLOUD WANT TO
BE THE BEST STRATEGIC PARTNER
TO
ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE
CHOOSING THAT DIGITAL
TRANSFORMATION JOURNEY.
AND WE BELIEVE
THAT WE CAN DO
THAT IN
TWO IMPORTANT WAYS. THE
FIRST WAY IS BRINGING
EXPERTISE TO HELP
YOU ON THAT JOURNEY.
AND THE SECOND, TO BE
THE EASIEST CLOUD
PROVIDER TO DO BUSINESS
WITH. TO HELP YOU
ON THAT
JOURNEY, WE'RE MASSIVELY
EXPANDING OUR GO TO MARKET
ORGANIZATION, NOT
JUST WITH SALESPEOPLE,
BUT WITH TECHNICAL
SPECIALISTS
WHO DEEPLY UNDERSTAND
TECHNOLOGY AND
INDUSTRIES AND CAN
HELP YOU IN YOUR
CUSTOMER SUCCESS ROLE
TO BUILD
GREAT NEW TRANSFORMATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES USING
OUR TECHNOLOGY
FOUNDATION.TO MAKE IT
EASY FOR OUR
CUSTOMERS WHO
DO BUSINESS WITH US,
WE ARE INTRODUCING A
VARIETY OF
NEW THINGS: SIMPLIFIED
PRICING, EASIER CONTRACTING,
CO INNOVATION
FRAMEWORKS WHERE WE CAN
WORK WITH YOU AND
PARTNERS, AND
WE RECOGNIZE PARTNERS
ARE VERY, VERY
IMPORTANT TO
GOOGLE, AND WE'RE
BROADENING OUR PARTNER
REACH AND
INTRODUCING A NUMBER OF
NEW ENHANCEMENTS IN OUR
PARTNER PROGRAM.WE
ARE VERY GRATEFUL TO
ALL OF YOU OUR
PARTNERS WHO HAVE
DONE SO MUCH TO
HELP US FURTHER OUR
MISSION TO
BEING SUCCESSFUL AS
A DIGITAL TRANSFORMATION
PROVIDER, AND
WE'VE SEEN A
4X GROWTH IN PARTNER
CERTIFICATIONS THIS
LAST YEAR, A
4X GROWTH IN DEVELOPER
CERTIFICATIONS, AND
A 6 TIMES GROWTH
IN DEVELOPER LEARNING HOURS,
ALL TESTAMENTS
TO THE INTEREST
IN OUR TECHNOLOGY AND
ALL TESTAMENTS
TO THE INTEREST
IN OUR TECHNOLOGY AND
HOW IT CAN HELP CUSTOMERS
ON THEIR JOURNEY TO DIGITAL
TRANSFORMATION. NOW, AT THE
FOUNDATION OF
THIS SITS OUR
DATA CENTER INFRASTRUCTURE.
GOOGLE
INVESTS ENORMOUS AMOUNTS
OF MONEY AND
TECHNOLOGY
SKILLS IN
BUILDING THE MOST
SOPHISTICATED DATA
CENTER INFRASTRUCTURE IN
THE WORLD. AND
HERE AT GOOGLE
NEXT, WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF IMPORTANT NEW
ANNOUNCEMENTS IN
THE CAPABILITIES WE OFFER
IN THE DATA CENTER.
WE ARE
INTRODUCING A NUMBER
OF IMPORTANT NEW THINGS
TO HELP
PEOPLE MIGRATE AND
MODERNIZE WORKLOADS WHEN
THEY SHIFT
TO THE CLOUD WITH
THE BEST INFRASTRUCTURE SOLUTIONS
FOR
CLOUD COMPUTING. WE'RE
INTRODUCING NEW
HARDWARE, BROADENING THE
NUMBER OF REGIONS WHERE
OUR CLOUD PRESENCE IS,
INTRODUCING
NEW CAPABILITIES
IN NETWORKING,
IN SOLE TENANCY,
WHICH GIVES YOU ISOLATION,
AND IN DNS PEERING
AND FORWARDING.
TO GIVE YOU A
LOT MORE DETAIL ABOUT
SOME OF THESE
CAPABILITIES AND HOW IT
CAN HELP YOU, OUR CUSTOMERS,
WITH MISSION
CRITICAL WORKLOADS, PLEASE
WELCOME BRAD CALDER,
VICE PRESIDENT
ENGINEERING FOR GOOGLE
CLOUD. BRAD.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THANKS, THOMAS.
SO MY TEAM
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR BUILDING
THE
CORE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
DELIVERS THE AVAILABILITY,
SECURITY,
AND PERFORMANCE
THAT ENTERPRISES NEED.
AND THE KEY
WORKLOAD WE HAVE FOCUSED
ON SUPPORTING IN GOOGLE CLOUD
IS SAP.
WHEN COMPANIES LOOK AT
MOVING MISSION CRITICAL WORKLOADS
TO THE CLOUD
SUCH AS SAP, THEY
NEED LARGE MEMORY
MACHINES. AND LAST YEAR
AT NEXT, I ANNOUNCED
THAT 6 TERABYTE AND
12 TERABYTE VIRTUAL
MACHINES WOULD BE COMING
AND I'M VERY PLEASED
TO ANNOUNCE TODAY THAT WE ARE
THE FIRST TO PROVIDE 12 TERABYTE
VIRTUAL MACHINES. YES.
[APPLAUSE]
NOW, IN ADDITION
TO LARGE MEMORY
MACHINES, SAP CUSTOMERS
ARE CHOOSING
GOOGLE CLOUD BECAUSE
OF OUR AVAILABILITY, SECURITY,
AND
FLEXIBILITY. SO LET'S
TALK ABOUT AVAILABILITY.
WHEN A SAP
SYSTEM GOES DOWN, BUSINESS
STOPS. NO FINANCIAL TRANSACTIONS,
NO MANUFACTURING,
NO TRANSPORTATION, NO
STOCKING OF SHELF.
EVERYTHING COMES TO
A HALT. ONE LIFE
SCIENCES SAP CUSTOMER SAID
THAT THEY LOSE
3 MILLION IN REVENUE
PER HOUR WHEN JUST
ONE OF
THEIR SAP SYSTEMS
GOES DOWN ON PREMISE.
YET FOR
DECADES, SAP ENTERPRISES
HAVE ACCEPTED DOWNTIME
DUE TO
HARDWARE, SOFTWARE, AND
OPERATING SYSTEM PATCHES.
AND STRATEGIES FOR
DEALING WITH THIS TEND
TO BE EXPENSIVE AND TOILSOME.
THIS DOWN TIME JUST
DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE. THAT IS
WHY WE DESIGNED GOOGLE CLOUD TO
VIRTUALLY ELIMINATE DOWNTIME, TO
KEEP YOUR CRITICAL APPLICATIONS
RUNNING AND AVAILABLE.
THIS ALL
HAPPENS TRANSPARENTLY FOR YOU
UNDER THE COVERS WITH
LIVE MIGRATION.
LIVE MIGRATION SEAMLESSLY
MIGRATES YOUR VM
BASED APPLICATIONS
IN THE BACKGROUND AND
IT KEEPS YOUR SAP
APPLICATIONS UP
AND RUNNING AND OPEN
FOR BUSINESS, EVEN IN
THE FACE
OF INFRASTRUCTURE MAINTENANCE,
UPGRADE SECURITY PATCHES,
AND MORE.NOW,
LET ME GIVE YOU
AN EXAMPLE. WHEN
GOOGLE RESEARCHERS
DISCOVERED THE
SPECTRE VULNERABILITY, WE
USED LIVE MIGRATION
TO PATCH EVERY SINGLE
GCP SERVER WITH
ZERO DOWN TIME
FOR OUR USERS.
SO OUR CUSTOMERS WERE
PROTECTED EVEN BEFORE
THEY KNEW THEY NEEDED
TO BE. AND WE
ARE THE ONLY
CLOUD THAT USES LIVE
MIGRATION ACROSS OUR FLEET.
THIS HELPS
KEEP YOUR WORKLOADS THAT
YOU RUN ON GOOGLE
CLOUD BOTH SAFE
AND AVAILABLE. NOW I
WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME
HANAN AND WILL
ON STAGE TO SHOW
YOU LIVE MIGRATION IN ACTION
ON SAP
USING OUR LARGE MEMORY VIRTUAL
MACHINES. HANAN.
>> LET'S START WITH
THE S/4HANA ERP SYSTEM. AT
THE TOP, OUR VM IS
RUNNING THE S/4
HANA APPLICATION. AT THE
BOTTOM, YOU CAN SEE
SAP DEMO HDB.
THAT'S OUR HANA DATABASE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT HOW
LIVE MIGRATION
WORKS. WHEN GOOGLE CLOUD
DETECTS AN EVENT, IT
IMMEDIATELY CREATES
ANOTHER COPY OF YOUR
VM ON ANOTHER HOST,
ONE THAT'S ALREADY
BEEN PATCHED. ONCE THE
NEW VM IS ON QUOTA
WITH THE OLD
VM, IT TAKES OVER
ITS IDENTITY AND TRAFFIC.
THIS WHOLE PROCESS,
THE MIGRATION FROM THE OLD
VM TO THE NEW ONE,
COMPLETES IN
UNDER ONE SECOND.RIGHT
NOW, WE ARE RUNNING
A STANDARD
SAP BENCHMARK FOR
A BUSY ENTERPRISE
SCENARIO, THOUSANDS OF
USERS CREATING SALES ORDERS,
RUNNING REPORTS AND MORE.
NOW, WE'RE GOING
TO TRIGGER MIGRATION USING
AN API THAT WE PROVIDE.
BY THE WAY,
YOU CAN USE THAT
API YOURSELF AND FIGURE OUT
HOW
YOUR WORKLOAD PERFORMS
WITH LIVE MIGRATION.
RIGHT NOW, IN
THE BACKGROUND, GCP IS
PINNING UP ANOTHER VM
AND COPYING
THE DATA OVER INCLUDING
MULTIPLE TERABYTES OF
MEMORY. NOW, LET'S SWITCH
OVER TO SLACKDRIVER
AND SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING.
IN THE TOP
LEFT WE SEE OUR
HISTORY OF LIVE MIGRATIONS.
THE ONE
WE JUST STARTED
WILL TAKE A MOMENT.
SO LET'S LOOK
AT SOME WE TRIGGERED
JUST BEFORE THE KEYNOTE STARTED.
WITH OTHER
CLOUD PROVIDERS, YOU
DON'T GET LIVE MIGRATION
SO YOU WOULD
HAVE AT LEAST A 30
MINUTE DOWN TIME TO REBOOT
AND RELOADING OF
ALL THIS DATA. AND IF
A REBOOT WAS DUE TO
A CRITICAL
SECURITY VULNERABILITY, YOU
MIGHT NOT EVEN GET
A CHOICE OF
WHEN IT HAPPENS. SOMEONE
ELSE CAN BE DECIDING
WHEN YOUR
BUSINESS IS DOWN. BUT
THE BOTTOM LEFT GRAPH
SHOWS THAT WITH
GOOGLE CLOUD, THERE HAS
BEEN ZERO DOWN TIME
FOR SYSTEM, DESPITE THE
MIGRATION. AS YOU CAN
SEE, THE SYSTEM CONTINUED
TO PROCESS
MORE THAN 20,000
TRANSACTIONS PER MINUTE
EVEN WHILE
IT WAS BEING
MIGRATED. WITHOUT LIVE MIGRATION,
YOU HAVE TO
MAKE A TRADE OFF
BETWEEN UP TIME AND SECURITY.
BUT WITH
LIVE MIGRATION, YOUR CRITICAL
BUSINESS APPLICATIONS STAY
AVAILABLE AND
SECURE.SO IN SUMMARY,
WE'VE JUST SHOWN YOU,
FORCING A
LIVE MIGRATION EVENT,
YOU SAW HOW THE
SYSTEM
STAYED FULLY AVAILABLE
THROUGH THE EVENT,
BY RUNNING
S/4HANA SYSTEM RUNNING INSIDE
THE GM ON GCP
PROCESSING
THOUSANDS OF
TRANSACTIONS. WE
ALSO SHOWED YOU THE 6 AND 12
TERABYTES VMs ARE NOW AVAILABLE
FOR EARLY TESTING, AND WE
EXPECT THEM TO BE SEP CERTIFIED
BY Q3 OF THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THANKS, HANAN. SO
AS YOU SAW, LIVE
MIGRATION HELPS KEEP YOUR
APPLICATION SECURE, AND
SECURITY IS TOP IN
MIND FOR SAP CUSTOMERS.
YOU CAN IMAGINE
THE SENSITIVITY OF THE
DATA INSIDE AN SAP SYSTEM,
FINANCIAL
DATA, CUSTOMER DATA,
HUMAN RESOURCE DATA,
AND MORE. AND
IN TERMS OF YOUR
DATA, GOOGLE DOES NOT ACCESS
CUSTOMER DATA
FOR ANY REASON
OTHER THAN THOSE NECESSARY
TO FILL
OUR CONTRACTUAL OBLIGATIONS.NOW,
ON TOP OF THAT,
GOOGLE CLOUD IS
THE FIRST TO OFFER ACCESS
TRANSPARENCY FOR YOUR DATA.
IN CASE
A GOOGLE CLOUD ENGINEER
NEEDS TO ACCESS DATA
FOR SUPPORT
PURPOSES, OUR ACCESS
TRANSPARENCY FEATURE PROVIDES
YOU WITH LOGS
OF THAT ACCESS, ALONG
WITH JUSTIFICATION AS TO WHY.
AND ONLY AT
GOOGLE IS ALL OF
YOUR STORAGE STORED ENCRYPTED
AT REST
BY DEFAULT WITHOUT YOU
HAVING TO DO ANYTHING.
AND IF YOU
EVEN WANT ANY  WANT
MORE CONTROL OVER YOUR DATA,
THE BEST WAY
TO ACHIEVE THAT IS
TO ADD ANOTHER LAYER OF
ENCRYPTION OVER
THAT DATA WITH
KEYS THAT YOU CONTROL
AND MANAGE YOURSELF.
AND TO PROVIDE THIS,
WE OFFER A FULL RANGE
OF
ENCRYPTION TECHNOLOGIES
INTEGRATED WITH OUR STACK.
THIS
INCLUDES CUSTOMER MANAGED
ENCRYPTION KEYS AND
SOLUTIONS TO MANAGE AND
PROTECT YOUR KEYS LIKE OUR CLOUD
KEY MANAGEMENT SERVICE AND OUR
FIPS CERTIFIED HARDWARE
SECURITY MODULES.
SO THESE ARE JUST A FEW WAYS
GOOGLE CLOUD
HELPS KEEP YOUR
SAP FINANCIAL CUSTOMER, EMPLOYEE,
AND OTHER
DATA SAFE AND
SECURE.SO WE TALKED
ABOUT AVAILABILITY
AND SECURITY. NOW
LET'S TALK ABOUT
FLEXIBILITY. BETWEEN
NOW AND 2025,
SAP CUSTOMERS HAVE TO
MIGRATE TO THE
LATEST VERSION OF ERP
CALLED S/4HANA AND TO
DO THIS, THEY
NEED LOTS OF CORES AND
LOTS OF MEMORY.NOW, IN
DOING THIS MIGRATION,
IT'S HARD FOR
CUSTOMERS TO DETERMINE
THE EXACT CONFIGURATIONS
THAT WILL BE NEEDED
AND IT'S HARD TO
PREDICT HOW THESE
SYSTEMS WILL GROW OVER
TIME. SO WHAT SAP
CUSTOMERS WANT IS
THE ABILITY TO BUY
A COMMITMENT FOR CLOUD
RESOURCES AND
HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY
TO ALLOCATE THOSE
RESOURCES ACROSS
THEIR WORKLOADS AS
NEEDED. AND GOOGLE CLOUD
PROVIDES THE
MOST FLEXIBILITY HERE AMONG
THE CLOUD PROVIDERS.
FOR EXAMPLE, YOU
CAN BUY A
COMMITTED USE DISCOUNT
AND USE
IT ACROSS ALL YOUR
VIRTUAL MACHINES TO MAXIMIZE
YOUR SAVINGS WITHOUT
GETTING LOCKED IN TO
SPECIFIC SHAPES AND SIZES,
AND YOU
CAN EASILY USE
THAT COMMITMENT WHEN SWITCHING
FROM SMALLER
TO LARGER VMs AS
YOUR SAP SYSTEMS GROW.
SO TO RECAP, WE
ARE PLEASED TO NOW
OFFER UP TO 12 TERABYTE
VIRTUAL MACHINES, AND
WE ARE THE ONLY
CLOUD THAT HELPS KEEP
YOUR APPLICATIONS
AND YOUR DATA
BOTH SECURE AND AVAILABLE
WITH OUR LIVE
MIGRATION, MULTI LAYER SECURITY,
AND OUR ACCESS TRANSPARENCY.
AND WE
PROVIDE THE MOST
FLEXIBILITY WITH OUR COMMITTED
USE DISCOUNTS TO
PREVENT YOU FROM GETTING
LOCKED IN TO SPECIFIC HARDWARE
AS YOUR
BUSINESS GROWS.AND NOW
I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME THOMAS
BACK ON STAGE
TO TELL YOU
ABOUT A CUSTOMER WHO'S MOVING
THEIR SAP WORKLOADS TO
GOOGLE CLOUD. THANK YOU.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THANK YOU, BRAD.
SO GOOGLE'S DESIGNING
OUR CLOUD TO RUN
MISSION CRITICAL
WORKLOADS. IT'S OUR
PRIVILEGE TO HAVE A
CUSTOMER WHO'S
BEEN A LONG TIME
CUSTOMER OF GOOGLE, AND
HE'S USING
A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT SERVICES WITHIN GOOGLE
CLOUD TO
HELP TRANSFORM HIS BUSINESS.
PLEASE WELCOME MIKE CROWE,
CHIEF INFORMATION
OFFICER OF COLGATE
PALMOLIVE. MIKE?
[APPLAUSE]
>> HI, THOMAS.
>> WELCOME.
>> THANK YOU.
IT MIGHT BE GOOD TO START
BY TELLING THE AUDIENCE
HOW YOUR
COMPANY GOT STARTED
WITH GOOGLE CLOUD.
Michael Crowe: CERTAINLY.
SO FIRST, THANKS
FOR HAVING ME, THOMAS.
COLGATE PALMOLIVE'S SUCCESS
INCREASINGLY REQUIRES GLOBAL
COLLABORATION. AND IN 2016 WE
KNEW WE NEEDED TO REVAMP
OUR COLLABORATION TECHNOLOGY.
WE CHOSE GSUITE.
I THINK OUR SUCCESS
WITH GSUITE IS WELL
DOCUMENTED SO I WON'T
GO INTO DETAILS,
BUT IN SUMMARY, WE BELIEVE
IT IS A SHINING
EXAMPLE OF CLOUD
DONE RIGHT. THE
REASONS WE CHOSE GSUITE
HAVE PLAYED
OUT FOR US: SECURITY,
A CONTINUOUS STREAM OF
INNOVATION AND
INTEGRATED ARCHITECTURE WITH
ALL THE RIGHT
LAYERS OF ABSTRACTION IN ORDER
TO MAXIMIZE AVAILABILITY
AND MINIMIZE DISRUPTION.
>> HOW HAS
YOUR GSUITE EXPERIENCE
CHANGED OR EVOLVED
YOUR THINKING ABOUT CLOUD?
>> WELL, WE'D
LOVE TO SEE ALL
OF OUR ENTERPRISE APPLICATIONS
WORK LIKE GSUITE.
NOT ALL OF THAT
IS IN OUR CONTROL,
BUT WE'RE
MOVING FORWARD WITH
WHAT WE CAN CONTROL.
WE ARE
INCREASINGLY TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
GCP TO BUILD ANALYTICS,
UTILIZING
YOUR MACHINE LEARNING
AND BIG QUERY CAPABILITIES,
AND WE HAVE
BEGUN TO MOVE SOME
OF THE ON PREMISE SOFTWARE
WE RUN IN
OUR DATA CENTER TO
GCP AS WELL.
>> YOU'RE A HUGE SAP
CUSTOMER. DES YOU MOVE TO THE
CLOUD INCLUDE SAP?
>> YES, THAT'S
CORRECT. OVER 25 YEARS, WE HAVE
BUILT A LARGE SAP FOOTPRINT,
TO A POINT
WHERE 100 PERCENT OF
OUR GLOBAL REVENUE RUNS
THROUGH THOSE SYSTEMS.
WE'VE REALLY JUST
BEGUN TO RUN SAP
ON GCP, BUT WE
DO HAVE AN EARLY SUCCESS.
LET ME TALK ABOUT ONE EXAMPLE.
IN OUR HILL'S
PET NUTRITION BUSINESS, WE
HAVE A PLATFORM WE
CALL HILLS TO
HOME. WHEN A VETERINARIAN
PRESCRIBES OUR PRESCRIPTION
DIET PET FOOD
TO TREAT AN AILING
DOG OR CAT, OUR PLATFORM
ALLOWS A VETERINARIAN
TO ENROLL THE PET
AND THE PET PARENT
IN A SUBSCRIPTION PROGRAM FOR THE
FOOD. THE PET PARENT ALSO HAS A
WEB AND MOBILE APPLICATION TO
MANAGE THEIR SUBSCRIPTION.
THE VET DOESN'T HAVE
TO CARRY INVENTORY ANYMORE.
THE PET
PARENT GETS FOOD
DELIVERED TO THEIR DOOR,
AND WE
DEVELOP A CLOSER RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE PET PARENT.
THAT'S A SUCCESS FOR
EVERYONE. AND GCP ALLOWED US
TO MOVE FAST. IF WE HAD
FOLLOWED OUR NORMAL
MO, WE WOULD HAVE
WAITED FOR SIX WEEKS
FOR HARDWARE TO ARRIVE,
SPENT ANOTHER WEEK OR TWO
INSTALLING AND CONFIGURING
EVERYTHING. INSTEAD, WE
PROVISIONED THE SYSTEMS ON
GCP AND THE NEXT DAY, THE TEAM
COULD START WORKING.
WE COULDN'T HAVE HIT
THE TARGET GO LIVE
WHICH WE
HAD, WHICH WAS
VERY AGGRESSIVE, WITHOUT HAVING
MADE THAT DECISION.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT HOW FAST WE STARTED.
WE ALSO
GET THE ADVANTAGES
GCP BRINGS, SECURITY,
REDUNDANCY, FLEXIBILITY,
AND SCALE. SINCE
THAT TIME, WE'VE
MOVED PAST
THE INITIAL PILOT. WE'VE
GONE INTO FULL PRODUCTION,
AND
THE APPLICATION
CONTINUES TO GROW.
>> I'M SO
GLAD FOR THE WORK YOUR
TEAM IS DOING WITH US.
THANK YOU FOR
BEING A CUSTOMER AND THANK
YOU FOR ALL THE WORK
YOU'VE DONE
USING GOOGLE CLOUD
TO CHANGE COLGATE.
>> AND THANKS TO
YOU AS WELL, THOMAS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
[APPLAUSE]
BUILT ON THIS
GLOBAL SCALE DISTRIBUTED
INFRASTRUCTURE, WE OFFER
A DIGITAL
TRANSFORMATION PLATFORM. IT
HAS FIVE IMPORTANT CAPABILITIES
FOR THE
DEVELOPER COMMUNITY AND
FOR IT ORGANIZATIONS:
THE ABILITY TO
BUILD GREAT APPS, TO
MANAGE LARGE QUANTITIES OF DATA,
TO DO
ANALYTICS, TO USE
AI MACHINE LEARNING,
AND TO COLLABORATE
WITH PEOPLE. TODAY WE'RE
GOING TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT
WE'RE DOING
FOR APPLICATION DEVELOPMENT.
WE'RE INTRODUCING
A NUMBER OF
AMAZING NEW FEATURES
FOR APPLICATION DEVELOPERS.
IT ALLOWS YOU TO
USE A CLOUD CODE
TO WRITE
GREAT APPLICATIONS, TO
RUN THESE APPLICATIONS
USING CLOUD RUN,
TO USE OUR OPEN
SOURCE CLOUD FUNCTIONS FRAMEWORK
TO EMPLOY
AND MANAGE THESE APPLICATIONS
WITH MUCH GREATER SIMPLICITY,
AND WE'VE INTEGRATED
ALL OF THESE TOOLS WITH
POPULAR OPEN SOURCE OFFERINGS;
FOR EXAMPLE, GITHUB,
GITLAB AND OTHERS. YOU'RE
GOING TO HEAR A LOT
MORE ABOUT
THIS AT THE DEVELOPER
KEYNOTE. I STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
EVERY ONE OF YOU TO GO TO
THAT KEYNOTE WHERE WE'RE GOING
TO SHOW YOU SOME AMAZING AND
COOL NEW
WAYS TO BUILD AMAZING
APPLICATIONS.NOW, GOOGLE
HAS ALSO HAD
A LONG HISTORY IN
BUILDING PLATFORMS THAT SERVE
AS ECOSYSTEMS.
SO OUR VIEW IS
THAT PLATFORMS THAT SUCCEED
WITH CUSTOMERS
ARE THOSE THAT
ENABLE ECOSYSTEMS, WHERE
THE
CLOUD PROVIDER'S TECHNOLOGY
IS COMPLEMENTED WITH
LEADING PRODUCTS
THAT CUSTOMERS AND
DEVELOPERS WANT TO USE.
THE FIRST SUCH
ECOSYSTEM IS WHAT WE
ARE DOING IN OPEN SOURCE.
GOOGLE HAS
HAD A LONG
HISTORY OF DEVELOPING TECHNOLOGY
AND MAKING
IT AVAILABLE IN OPEN
SOURCE TO FOSTER INNOVATION
BY DEVELOPERS.
BUT RECENTLY, THE
OPEN SOURCE COMMUNITY
HAS FOUND
THAT CLOUD PROVIDERS
ARE NOT PARTNERING
WITH THEM
BUT ATTEMPTING TO
TAKE AWAY THEIR ABILITY
TO MONETIZE OPEN
SOURCE. WE AS GOOGLE
DO NOT BELIEVE THAT
THAT IS
GOOD FOR CUSTOMERS,
FOR THE DEVELOPER COMMUNITY,
OR FOR
SOFTWARE INNOVATION. AS A
RESULT, WE HAVE PARTNERED
WITH LEADING
OPEN SOURCE COMPANIES
TO DELIVER OPEN SOURCE
TO OUR
DEVELOPER COMMUNITY AND
CUSTOMERS IN NEW WAYS.
WE ARE
VERY PLEASED TODAY
TO ANNOUNCE THE FIRST
INTEGRATED OPEN
SOURCE ECOSYSTEM. WHAT
THIS ALLOWS YOU TO
DO AS A DEVELOPER,
OR AS A CUSTOMER, IS
TO USE THE BEST BREED
OPEN SOURCE
TECHNOLOGY. YOU CAN
PROCURE THEM USING
STANDARD GOOGLE
CLOUD CREDITS. YOU GET
A SINGLE CONSOLE, A
SINGLE BILL
FROM GOOGLE. WE SUPPORT
THESE, ALONG WITH THE
PARTNERS, AND
AS YOU GROW AND
USE THESE TECHNOLOGIES, WE
SHARE OUR
SUCCESS WITH OUR PARTNERS.
SO WE'RE FOSTERING THIS
NEW OPEN
SOURCE COMMUNITY TO
ENSURE THAT OPEN SOURCE
CONTINUES TO THRIVE
AND HAS A VEHICLE
TO GROW IN THIS WORLD.
LET'S HEAR NOW
FROM THE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICERS OF
SOME OF
OUR IMPORTANT PARTNERS ABOUT
WHY THIS MATTERS SO
MUCH TO THE WORLD,
TO THE DEVELOPER COMMUNITY,
AND TO THE ECOSYSTEM.
>> WHEN
YOU CHANGE INFRASTRUCTURE, IT'S
VERY MUCH AKIN TO
CHANGING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE CITY.
IT'S NO SMALL UNDERTAKING
WHEN THERE'S
ALREADY BUILDINGS THAT EXIST.
THAT'S WHY WE TURN
TO GOOGLE CLOUD AS A PARTNER.
>> WHEN I TALK
TO CUSTOMERS, THE COMMON
THEME I HEAR FROM EVERY
CUSTOMER IS THEY
WANT TO BE ABLE
TO INNOVATE MORE QUICKLY.
BUT THE DATA
LANDSCAPE IS MORE COMPLICATED
THAN IT USED TO BE.
PEOPLE NEED TO
ACTUALLY BRIDGE BETWEEN ALL
THESE DIFFERENT SYSTEMS.
>> ALL THE DEVICES,
ALL THE MOBILE APPS, ALL
THE THINGS IN YOUR WORLD
THAT ARE
GENERATING MILLIONS, BILLIONS,
TRILLIONS OF TRANSACTIONS.
>> IN THE PAST,
THAT USED TO BE ALL
STORED IN DATABASES THAT WERE
GREAT AT
STORING STRUCTURED DATA
BUT REALLY BAD AT
STORING
HOW DATA
WAS RELATED.
>> AND AS
PEOPLE NOW STARTED MOVING
WORKLOADS FROM ON PREMISE
TO THE CLOUD,
THEY HAVE TO START
THINKING ABOUT WHAT IS
THE DATABASE
THEY WANT TO
RUN THOSE WORKLOADS ON.
>> WITH GOOGLE
CLOUD, YOU GET THE
ADVANTAGE OF BEING ABLE TO
ACCESS A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF ML/AI CAPABILITY
AND OTHER SERVICES.
>> AND DATA
CENTERS IN MANY, MANY, MANY
LOCATIONS ALL AROUND THE WORLD
THAT ENTERPRISES
COULD NEVER AFFORD
ON THEIR OWN.
>> AND THIS
IS ALL ABOUT REAL
TIME STREAMS OF EVENTS
AND HOW CAN
YOU HARNESS ALL THE
STREAMS OF DATA
THEY HAVE WHILE
THEY'RE INTERACTING WITH
THE CUSTOMER.
>> I STARTED ELASTIC
SEARCH ON MY OWN, AND THERE
WAS NO WAY THAT A SINGLE
PERSON WOULD BE ABLE TO
SUCCESSFULLY CREATE SUCH
A TOOL WITH SUCH A LEVEL OF
ADOPTION WITHOUT OPEN SOURCE.
>> THE RICHNESS
OF THAT ECOSYSTEM OPENS
UP THIS WHOLE MARKETPLACE
OF DATA
SYSTEMS THAT YOU
CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF.
>> AND THE
KEY CONSTITUENTS TO DO
THAT IS THE DEVELOPER,
BEING ABLE
TO SELECT THE
TECHNOLOGIES AND ENABLE THEM
TO
INNOVATE AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
>> AND THAT'S
WHERE GOOGLE REALLY HAS
SOMETHING SPECIAL TO OFFER.
THE WAY
THEY THINK ABOUT THIS
PROBLEM SET IS VERY
BUILDER/DEVELOPER ORIENTED,
WHICH IS UNIQUE AMONG
THE MAJOR CLOUD PROVIDERS.
>> ENABLING
THE COLLABORATION OF
THE PERSON THAT PRODUCES
A SOFTWARE
AND THE PERSON
THAT CONSUMES THE SOFTWARE.
WHENEVER YOU
COLLAPSE THESE TWO TOGETHER,
THAT'S WHEN MAGIC HAPPENS.
>> PUTTING ALL THESE
OPEN SOURCE COMPANIES IN ONE
PLACE IS A REAL SMART STRATEGY.
THE CUSTOMER CAN
GO TO ONE PLACE
AND GET BEST OF
BREED SOLUTIONS WITH
A UNIFIED EXPERIENCE.>>
THIS PARTNERSHIP IS ABOUT
THIS NEXT GENERATION
OF OPEN SOURCE COMPANIES
BUILDING THESE INCREASINGLY
>> THIS PARTNERSHIP
IS ABOUT THIS NEXT GENERATION
OF OPEN SOURCE COMPANIES
BUILDING THESE INCREASINGLY
>> THIS PARTNERSHIP
IS ABOUT THIS NEXT GENERATION
OF OPEN SOURCE COMPANIES
BUILDING
THESE INCREASINGLY
SMARTER SYSTEMS.
>>
THINGS THAT MAY
SEEM INSURMOUNTABLE JUST
A FEW
YEARS AGO HAVE NOW BECOME
IMMINENTLY POSSIBLE.
>> GOOGLE IS ACTUALLY
THE FASTEST GROWING PART
OF OUR CLOUD BUSINESS TODAY,
AND WE
THINK WE'RE JUST
SCRATCHING THE SURFACE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF REDIS LABS
OFER BENGAL IS HERE.
PLEASE GIVE HIM
A WARM WELCOME, AND
HE'LL TELL YOU MORE
ABOUT OUR PARTNERSHIP
AND WHAT IT MEANS
TO HIS COMPANY. OFER?
WELCOME. WELCOME, OFER.
TELL US A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT REDIS LABS
AND
YOUR PARTNERSHIP WITH
GOOGLE CLOUD.
>> SURE. SO FIRSTLY,
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
IT'S A GREAT EVENT.
SO OUR
PARTNERSHIP GOES BACK TO
2014, WHEN WE FIRST
LAUNCHED REDIS
ENTERPRISE, OUR FULLY
MANAGED REDIS SERVICE,
ON THE GOOGLE CLOUD,
AND THIS PARTNERSHIP
HAS EVOLVED SIGNIFICANTLY
EVER SINCE.
WE ALWAYS SHARED
WITH GOOGLE THE BELIEF
THAT OUR
CUSTOMERS AND US
CAN GREATLY BENEFIT
FROM OUR
INVESTMENTS IN THE OPEN
SOURCE COMMUNITY.
>> WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT
THE STRATEGIC INITIATIVE
WE ANNOUNCED TODAY?
>> WELL, THIS
STRATEGIC INITIATIVE IS GREAT FOR
US BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW,
MONETIZING OPEN
SOURCE WAS ALWAYS A
VERY BIG CHALLENGE FOR
OPEN SOURCE
VENDORS AND MORE SO
IN THE CLOUD ERA.NOW,
GOOGLE HAS
TAKEN A VERY
DIFFERENT APPROACH FROM OTHER
CLOUD VENDOR WHEN
IT COMES TO OPEN
SOURCE, AND I THINK THAT
THIS IS GREAT
NEWS FOR THE OPEN
SOURCE COMMUNITY. BUT NO
WONDER, I MEAN, GOOGLE
HAS DEEP ROOTS IN
OPEN SOURCE FOR YEARS
WITH
INVESTMENTS IN
PROJECTS LIKE TENSORFLOW,
KUBERNETES, ET
CETERA, BUT I THINK
THAT TODAY WITH THIS
INITIATIVE, YOU
TOOK IT TO THE
NEXT LEVEL.
>> HOW DO YOU THINK
THIS PARTNERSHIP CAN BENEFIT
OUR JOINT CUSTOMERS?
>> SO I
THINK THAT CUSTOMERS CAN
NOW CONSUME REDIS ENTERPRISE,
WHICH IS
OUR MANAGED SERVICE, WITH
THE SAME USER EXPERIENCE
AS THEY
HAVE WITH OTHER NATIVE
GOOGLE CLOUD SERVICES. AND
WHEN I SAY
SAME USER EXPERIENCE, I MEAN
THE SAME STYLE UI, THE
SAME SUPPORT,
SAME BUILDING, ET CETERA,
ET CETERA. SO NOW
THEY CAN
SELECT FOR CERTAIN USE
CASES NATIVE CLOUD SERVICES
BY GOOGLE CLOUD,
AND THEN FOR OTHER
USE CASES THEY CAN
SELECT BEST
OF BREED ENTERPRISE GRADE
SERVICES BY THIRD PARTY
PROVIDERS LIKE REDIS
ENTERPRISE. AND IN THE
CASE OF REDIS, I
THINK THAT, YOU
KNOW, WHEN IT COMES
TO CERTAIN USE CASES,
USERS CAN
SELECT CLOUD MEMORY STORE,
WHICH IS THE NATIVE
REDIS SERVICE
BY THE GOOGLE CLOUD,
AND THEN FOR MORE
ADVANCE, FOR
MORE SOPHISTICATED USE
CASES, SUCH AS ACTIVE
ACTIVE DISTRIBUTION FOR
REDIS, OR REDIS AS
A MULTI MODEL DATABASE,
THEY CAN GO
FOR REDIS ENTERPRISE. I'D
LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT REDIS
ENTERPRISE IS TIGHTLY
INTEGRATED WITH SOME OF
THE CUTTING EDGE
TECHNOLOGIES OF THE GOOGLE
CLOUD. SO, FOR EXAMPLE,
OUR ACTIVE
ACTIVE DISTRIBUTION LEVERAGES
THE FAST GLOBAL
NETWORK OF THE
GOOGLE CLOUD AND TRUE
TIME, AND OUR REDIS
AND FLASH
TECHNOLOGY IS TIGHTLY
INTEGRATED WITH NVME
AND PERSISTENT
MEMORY OFFERINGS BY THE
GOOGLE CLOUD. SO ALL
IN ALL, I THINK
IT'S A MATCH MADE
IN HEAVEN.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH, OFER.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PARTNERSHIP.
THANK YOU FOR
WHAT YOUR
COMPANY AND YOUR DEVELOPERS
ARE DOING WITH US.
>> GREAT PLEASURE.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[APPLAUSE]
IF YOU'RE TRYING TO IMAGINE
HOW WOULD YOU AS A DEVELOPER OR
CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE THIS SOLUTION,
LET ME
WELCOME GOPAL FROM
OUR PRODUCT ORGANIZATION
TO COME UP
AND SHOW YOU THIS
IN ACTION. GOPAL.
>> THANK YOU,
THOMAS. AS THOMAS
MENTIONED, WE WANT OUR
CUSTOMERS BUILDING
APPLICATIONS ON OPEN
SOURCE TO HAVE CHOICE.
THE CHOICE
OF USING GOOGLE
MANAGED OPEN SOURCE
SERVICE OR
VALUE ADDED SERVICES FROM
OUR OPEN SOURCE PARTNERS.
LET'S TAKE THE
EXAMPLE OF THE NEW
YORK TIMES. THEY HAVE
AN APPLICATION
THAT REQUIRES A
HIGHLY AVAILABLE RETICENCE
BUT THEY
ALSO HAVE USE CASES
THAT CAN BENEFIT FROM
REDIS
ENTERPRISE FEATURES
LIKE GEODISTRIBUTED CASH.
WOULDN'T IT BE
GREAT IF NEW YORK
TIMES CAN USE BOTH CLOUD
MEMORY STORE
AND REDIS ENTERPRISE
AND HAVE A SEAMLESS
EXPERIENCE BETWEEN
THE TWO?WITH THIS
ANNOUNCEMENT, WE ARE
ENABLING JUST THAT.
SO LET'S TAKE A
LOOK AT FEW OF THE
ELEMENTS OF
THE EXPERIENCE. NUMBER
ONE, UNIFIED SUPPORT.
GOOGLE WILL PROVIDE
THE FIRST LINE OF
SUPPORT FOR ALL THESE SERVICES.
NUMBER TWO,
UNIFIED BILLING. YOU WILL
GET ONE SINGLE BILL
FROM GOOGLE
ACROSS ALL THE
GOOGLE AND PARTNER SERVICES.
AND
NUMBER THREE, UNIFIED
EXPERIENCE, A SEAMLESS
PRODUCT EXPERIENCE
WHERE YOU CAN
USE THE SAME MANAGEMENT
TOOLS FOR
BOTH GOOGLE AND PARTNER
SERVICES.SO LET'S TAKE A
LOOK AT THE
PRODUCT EXPERIENCE. WE ARE
MAKING IT VERY EASY
FOR YOU TO
DISCOVER PARTNER SERVICES. AS
YOU CAN SEE IN THE
GOOGLE CONSOLE,
WE ARE LISTING
ALL THE VARIOUS PARTNER
SERVICES ON
THE LEFT NOW ALONG
WITH THE GOOGLE SERVICES.
LET'S TAKE A
LOOK AT REDIS ENTERPRISE
AS AN EXAMPLE. HERE YOU
SEE THE
SOLUTIONS PAGE WHERE YOU
GET ALL THE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE SERVICE.
YOU CAN ENABLE THE API,
OR YOU CAN MANAGE IT.
LET'S CLICK ON
MANAGE. HERE YOU SEE THE
LIST OF ALL THE REDIS
ENTERPRISE CLUSTERS
THAT WE HAVE
ALREADY CREATED. BUT LET'S
TAKE A LOOK
AT WHAT THE EXPERIENCE
LOOKS LIKE WHEN YOU
CREATE A
NEW REDIS ENTERPRISE CLUSTER.
THE CREATION FLOW IS
BUILT DIRECTLY
INTO THE GOOGLE CLOUD
CONSOLE SO AS A
CUSTOMER YOU
DON'T HAVE TO GO
TO AN EXTERNAL PARTNER
PORTAL TO
PROVISION THE SERVICE.OVER
HERE, YOU CAN SELECT
REDIS ENTERPRISE
FEATURES LIKE REDIS
ON FLASH, SELECT GCP
SETTINGS LIKE
REGIONS AND NETWORKS.LET'S
GO AND ADD A
DATABASE TO
THE CLUSTER. IF
YOU HAVE APPLICATIONS THAT
REQUIRES CAPABILITIES
LIKE SEARCH OR GRAPH,
YOU CAN NOW ADD
REDIS ENTERPRISE
MODULES WHILE CREATING
THE DATABASE. CLICK CREATE,
YOU HAVE
A REDIS ENTERPRISE
CLUSTER CREATED DIRECTLY FROM
THE CLOUD CONSOLE.
AS YOU CAN SEE,
THE EXPERIENCE IS EXACTLY
THE SAME
AS YOU WOULD GET
WITH OTHER CLOUD SERVICES,
GOOGLE CLOUD
SERVICES LIKE SQL
OR CLOUD MEMORY STORE.
PROVISIONING IS JUST
A START. YOU
CAN ALSO MANAGE THE
REDIS ENTERPRISE CLUSTER
FROM THE CONSOLE. LET'S
TAKE A LOOK
AT ONE OF THE CLUSTERS
THAT WE'VE ALREADY PROVISIONED.
HERE YOU SEE THE LIST OF DATABASES
THAT IS IN THE CLUSTER, THE
STATUS OF THE DATABASE, THE
PROPERTIES, ET CETERA. BUT LET'S
DOUBLE CLICK INTO
ONE OF THE DATABASES.
OVER HERE, WE GIVE
YOU ALL
THE INFORMATION ABOUT
THE DATABASE, BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY, YOU
CAN MONITOR REDIS
ENTERPRISE DIRECTLY FROM
THE CONSOLE. SO
NOW YOU HAVE A
UNIFIED MANAGEMENT PLANE
THAT ALLOWS YOU
TO MANAGE AND
MONITOR BOTH GOOGLE
SERVICES AND
PARTNER SERVICES.IT DOESN'T
END THERE. IF YOU
WANT ADVANCED MONITORING,
YOU CAN USE STACKDRIVER. OVER
HERE, WE HAVE CREATED A
STACKDRIVER DASHBOARD THAT GETS
METRICS DIRECTLY FROM THE
REDIS ENTERPRISE DATABASE.AND
LASTLY, IF YOU
HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT ANY
OF THESE, YOU CAN CALL
GOOGLE SUPPORT. THAT'S
RIGHT. A SINGLE POINT
OF CONTACT FOR
SUPPORT.IN SUMMARY,
WHEN YOU
ARE BUILDING APPLICATIONS
USING OPEN SOURCE
ON GCP, YOU NOW
HAVE CHOICE, THE CHOICE OF
USING GOOGLE
MANAGED OPEN SOURCE
SERVICES OR VALUE ADDED
SERVICES FROM
OUR OPEN SOURCE
PARTNERS DELIVERED TO YOU
WITH A UNIFIED SUPPORT,
BILLING, AND PRODUCT EXPERIENCE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THANK YOU, GOPAL.
SO WHEN YOU CAME
TO GOOGLE CLOUD NEXT
THIS MORNING,
YOU PROBABLY NEVER
THOUGHT YOU WOULD SEE
THE ABILITY TO
BUILD A WORKLOAD, RUN
IT IN YOUR DATA CENTER
AND HAVE
THAT WORKLOAD BE
MOVABLE TO GOOGLE CLOUD
OR ANY
OTHER PUBLIC CLOUD PROVIDER
WITH ZERO CHANGE, ANTHOS.
WHEN YOU CAME
TO GOOGLE CLOUD THIS
MORNING, GOOGLE CLOUD NEXT,
YOU PROBABLY DID NOT EXPECT
TO SEE ALL THE INNOVATIONS WE'RE
INTRODUCING IN INFRASTRUCTURE,
THE ONLY CLOUD
THAT ALLOWS YOU TO
RUN MISSION CRITICAL
WORKLOAD LIKE SAP
ON VIRTUAL ENVIRONMENT WHICH
GIVES YOU BETTER SECURITY,
BETTER
PERFORMANCE, BETTER RELIABILITY
AND LOWER RISK.
WHEN YOU CAME
TO GOOGLE CLOUD
NEXT THIS MORNING,
YOU PROBABLY NEVER
THOUGHT THAT YOU COULD
USE THE BEST OF BREED
OPEN SOURCE
TECHNOLOGY AS A
DEVELOPER, USING GOOGLE CLOUD
CREDITS AND
THAT GOOGLE WOULD
SHARE OUR SUCCESS
WITH THESE PARTNERS
SO THAT YOU CAN
CONTINUE TO INNOVATE USING
THESE TECHNOLOGIES.THESE
ARE JUST THREE
EXAMPLES OF GREAT
NEW
THINGS WE'RE INTRODUCING
IN GOOGLE CLOUD.
OVER THE NEXT
TWO DAYS, WE HAVE
A HOST OF OTHER
ANNOUNCEMENTS TOMORROW
IN THE KEYNOTE, AND
IN MANY SESSIONS TODAY.
NOT ONLY
WILL YOU HEAR ABOUT
ALL THE GREAT THINGS
THAT WE'RE
INTRODUCING AND THAT
PARTNERS ARE INTRODUCING,
WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE OVER
400 CUSTOMERS TALKING ABOUT
HOW THEY
HAVE USED GOOGLE CLOUD
TO CHANGE THEIR BUSINESS
AND HOW THEY
ARE SUCCEEDING IN USING
IT AS A PLATFORM
TO ENABLE
DIGITAL TRANSFORMATION. I HOPE
THE NEXT TWO DAYS
WILL BE A GREAT
TIME FOR ALL OF YOU
TO LEARN ABOUT THESE TECHNOLOGIES
AND HOW
THEY CAN HELP
YOU TRANSFORM YOUR ORGANIZATION.
WE HAVE A LOT
OF SESSIONS TODAY. FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO ARE WATCHING
ON
STREAMING, PLEASE CONTINUE
TO WATCH BECAUSE
WE WILL
CONTINUE TO BROADCAST
ON THE STREAMING
NETWORK A
NUMBER OF SESSIONS
TODAY AND TOMORROW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
AND A WARM WELCOME TO OUR
CLOUD EVENT. THANK YOU.
[APPLAUSE]